ok ok là ça y est je sais pas pourquoi
le son c'est déconnecté vous savez c'est
une habitude quand je stream quand je
lance un premier stream en tout cas
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
très très bien donc c'est la quatrième
édition aujourd'hui du champion donc on
va faire un petit rappel des règles
générales de l'événement donc regarde un
petit peu tout ce que nous avons eu ce
qu'on a les joueurs qui vont apparaître
alors j'ai voulu faire défiler un peu
moi-même en commençant avec Magnus
Carlson on a karwana ici
au premier le premier qui est ici c'est
ça change tout seul on a un châteauf
donc herberg 18 ans qui a devoir gagner
une mission il y a quelques mois on a
malus Carlson donc ancien champion du
monde qui est maintenant le meilleur
joueur sur le point de vue hello
kervanna Fabian qui avait 3e à la Coupe
du Monde dernièrement on va avoir ici
Pavel elianov alors un joueur à 2007
ukrainien parce qu'ils connaissent pas
on a bien sûr à lire les infos déjà
notre français on aura aussi Denis cela
va vite d'un joueur qui a confirmé déjà
nombreuses fois dans les tournois
rapides sur cheescom on a so Wesley qui
est hyper connu sur le circuit et
maintenant abîme pendant amine tabac
Tabeille donc un joueur un joueur
iranien alors pour les brackets mais la
raquette sont ici
donc je vous rappelle un petit peu les
règles rapidement vous allez avoir 15
scène qui va affronter tabac Tabe donc
ce sont des parties de 15 minutes plus 3
secondes par coup on va voir laservic
contre Karana
sauf contre elianov et un très gros choc
déjà c'est abdos contre firoza et là
c'est déjà bon je pense qu'on va
regarder ce ce duel
en priorité
même si tous les duels intéresse mais je
pense qu'on va regarder celui-là en
priorité déjà parce que il est français
et en plus Abdou en face qui a déjà
gagné un événement fille roux il est
hyper chaud aussi c'est un va vraiment
être je pense le match de la journée
pour tout ce qui est
événement regarder donc on a eu un
événement avec 45 à gagner deuxième
événement c'est Naka qui l'a emporté
troisième c'était Abdou qui avait marqué
sur tout le monde quatrième ça avait été
carcène deuxième fois et aujourd'hui
commence du coup le
le quatrième pardon non il y a eu bien
sûr
le
le Dieu de Berck qui commence
aujourd'hui et on va avoir un petit peu
qui peut gagner donc là n'a qu'à n'est
pas là aujourd'hui et on va voir un
petit 47 ou un petit Abdou qui peut qui
peut peut-être
essayer de gagner la troisième édition
du tournoi et on a bien sûr encore une
fois beaucoup de joueurs très très bons
qui sont font partie de l'événement
alors pour le format regardez bien alors
on a déjà de base je vais vous traduire
un petit peu un petit peu tout ce petit
tableau qui est qui est là qui est
l'arbitre de comprendre on a de base un
tournoi qualif
dans lesquels on va se qualifier pour
l'événement
alors ensuite les trois premiers joueurs
et Ben sont qualifiés pour le double
Berg
ensuite regardez vainqueur d'événements
il me casse le tour vous avez 8 joueurs
de joueurs vont directement en face
finale les joueurs classés entre 3 et 6
voilà en gros vous avez vous avez des
joueurs qui se qualifient
automatiquement pour
pour les phases suivantes et bonjour à
tout le monde sur le chat salut Fatou
salut Janus wheels salut Fabien normand
ça lui demande vrai salut Yumi salut
root salut à tous je sais pas s'ils ont
oublié dans le chat on avait Cécile et
les joueurs se répètent avec robineta
qui était là bien sûr je voudrais dire
aussi le chat de Youtube je vois les
deux chats en même temps donc c'est des
parties qui sont sur internet en 15 + 3
pour l'instant
voilà voilà je crois j'ai un deuxième
j'avais un deuxième petit voilà ça c'est
un vous avez aussi les califes qui sont
prévus ici donc c'est un combat Suisse
en 10 + 2 qui sont ouverts à tous les GM
plus les qualifiés des phases
précédentes et ensuite une fois qu'on a
dans les tableaux et ben vous avez 8
joueurs dans la division 1 alors la
division 1 c'est vraiment les colosses
c'est vraiment les meilleurs gens donc
c'est 15 + 3 la cadence les trois
premiers de la Division 1 reste en
division
le vainqueur de la division 2 se
qualifie pour la division 1 et après
vous avez 32 joueurs dans la division 3
pour vous tiser un petit peu et ben je
regarde un petit peu les divisions et
j'ai vu qu'on avait Laurent Freyssinet
qui faisait partie de la division 2
ainsi que Étienne Bacro qui jouait dans
la division 3 donc on ira un petit peu
jeter un coup d'oeil alors parti
malheureusement j'aurais pas de caméra
sur eux mais on pourra aller voir un peu
ce qu'ils font dans leur division
respective et dernière petite chose
intéressante et bien vous avez ici
le trophée donc moi je le trouve hyper
le trophée du champions qui sera remis
au vainqueur vraiment de toutes les
questions que je vous rappelle qu'il y a
en tout six éditions là c'est la
quatrième et
et donc donc voilà vous avez ce trophée
qui sera remis au
vainqueur de la saison donc il y aura
quatre parties par match Antoine
et on va je vais vous mettre la scène où
j'apparais les gens sont pas encore là
en fait dans mes joueurs moi j'ai tout
le monde sauf bien sûr j'allais dire sur
le pont du monde mais c'est plus
champion du monde maïs cars scène il se
fait attendre c'est le seul que je n'ai
pas dans les caméras donc sinon j'allais
vous mettre là je vérifie s'il est
arrivé et je vois qu'il n'est toujours
pas arrivé le petit Magnus tout le monde
est là à attendre le départ alors le
départ je sais pas à quelle heure c'est
je crois que moi m'avait 17h mais à
priori avec l'expérience que j'ai fait
déjà stream de cet événement souvent à
15 donc je me suis encore fait avoir
donc normalement on a encore peut-être
quelques minutes avant le début de
l'événement dans car ce n'est pas là je
peux vous mettre si vous voulez
le la scène avec avec Abdou et et
virus va bon
voilà vous avez la scène les gens sont
pas là les enfants arrivés très bientôt
en tout cas et Laurent a commencé alors
c'est vrai que les parties sont sont
décalés on commence pas tous en même
temps donc Laurent je pense que je peux
aller le voir mais je suis pas sûr
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr de faire une bêtise si
je bouge je vais essayer d'aller voir si
vous voulez on va la division 2 est-ce
qu'on a un petit Laurent qui est là j'ai
Laurent j'irai changer par contre quand
on commencera les autres d'ailleurs je
vais venir sur cette scène là comme ça
vous allez voir que
vous tournez le chéquier aussi on va
tout faire bien ici
Laurent aller devant cette partie contre
driver c'est un colosse aussi c'est un
gros un gros dur vous voyez il a 2700
hello et ça va être un match très
intéressant alors par contre la division
2 je suis pas sûr à 1000%. je crois que
la division 2 il joue en deux parties
aller-retour tandis que dans les visions
4 dans les jours un pardon ils sont à
quatre parties donc on va voir un peu
comment ça joue ça c'est la première
partie donc ça a commencé comment je
prends le début de partie hop
D4 des 5 C4 il a joué aussi ce qui est
hyper classique avec ces trois C5
prise dans des cadres cavaliers 6 et
puis on prend des 5 alors ce petit pion
en dessin qu'il doit être prenable je
pense que ça va prendre des sacs on va
voir fous aussi s'il me semble et l'idée
en fait c'est d'avoir un droit une
grosse avance de développement avec nos
pièces Georges Luc cavaler des cadres
qui avait les P4 qui peut arriver et
ouais j'ai quand même trois pièces
développées bien noir contre une seule
chez les Blancs il y a un pion au moins
mais j'ai l'activité donc c'est
intéressant c'est un choix intéressant
d'avoir de Laurent il y a eu 3 cavalier
F6 et les blancs préfèrent jouer sur le
pion isolé
en dessin donc c'est une partie
tranquille pour l'instant
je peux vous montrer de la qualité de
l'air de tous les joueurs dans les jours
arriveront et R6 du coup c'est un petit
truc alors généralement quand je
commente l'événement je suis avec je
suis avec Laurent et Laurent et ben il a
son petit boîtier rings qui purifie
l'air de sa pièce donc pour ceux qui
travaillent à domicile enfin plutôt à la
maison c'est sympa quand même d'avoir
sur l'appareil qui te dis un petit peu
si l'air est bon là n'est pas bon etc
etc moi j'ai rien vous savez moi j'ai
rien du tout ici mon mur est bien ou pas
bien donc à tout moment stouf hein
moi j'ai pas assez chez moi
malheureusement je
mais pourquoi pas un jour
alors ils ont un appareil alors du coup
du coup c'est vrai que que Laurent
avec je crois que c'est 24 et ben ils
avaient déjà fait des événements comme
ça et puis ils avaient tous eu un petit
Racing et moi je n'ai pas eu
moi ma délaissé
et je prends volontiers
d'ailleurs après je vous enverrai vous
savez que avec qu'est-ce que on adore
vous envoyer des pubs et donc là
aujourd'hui encore une fois l'événement
il est fait il est sponsorisé par
beaucoup beaucoup
de sponsors et en encore une fois pas
mal de pubs qui sont traduits en
français donc traduit vous savez par par
notre traducteur favori Sami Robin qui
d'ailleurs auteur du livre avec Kevin
bordi donc voilà on a tout ça qui est
prêt tout à l'heure dès que la partie de
Carlson sera terminée on essaiera de
voir un petit peu
les pubs ensemble les voir un peu ce qui
se passe en tout cas alors ça Rama qui
est toujours là
merci et on a d'autres encore donc ça
vous les verrez en tout cas c'est
on va suivre bâti on s'en fout un peu de
Magnus alors déjà dans la première
division on va suivre firou parce que la
division on a des caméras tout ça et
puis et puis ce qu'elle m'a dit la
division 1 quoi
dans les divisions 3 et et Laurent
Freyssinet dans les divisions 2 mais
avant j'ai pas les caméras sur les
joueurs j'ai rien donc on peut suivre un
petit peu comme ça mais on va quand même
plutôt de même priorité à la division 1
après on fera des sauts on va quand même
voir ce qui se passe promis je vous
tiens au courant de tout le résultat des
Français dans toutes les divisions
et d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que on
avait une belle surprise avec avec jus
de Moussa donc lors du tout en événement
qui avait participé qui avait d'ailleurs
très très bien marché dans ce tournoi il
avait perdu en première partie contre
contrats et
Abdul avait été juste implacable et au
final il avait perdu il me semble contre
kerwana si j'ai pas de bêtises
et ce qu'il a il a perdu il m'a pris il
avait eu des appariements intéressants
il avait réussi à gagner deux parties
d'affilée deux matchs d'affilée j'arrive
plus à me souvenir des adversaires mais
il avait gagné deux matchs intéressants
je crois qu'il avait besoin en allemand
je sais plus lequel un truc comme ça il
avait joué un autre joueur
un Russe je sais plus comment il
s'appelle en 2006 et il avait fini par
perdre contre karwana et il avait quand
même bien avancé c'était vraiment un
super tournoi de la part de Jules
donc B6 d'ailleurs j'aime bien ces
petits tournois qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de cette tournoi c'est tournoi
vous savez
du style double élimination ces systèmes
coupe mais W l'élimination ça veut dire
que si on perd un match on peut revenir
par la poudre et perdants et remonter
jusqu'à la vraie finale qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est débile ou est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est intéressant moi j'aime
bien je trouve que c'est pas mal
par exemple
par exemple vous avez sur place France
les échecs qui s'est terminé il y a
quelques jours et je trouvais que la
formule est un petit peu un petit peu
dur
de parties éliminer à voir je trouvais
que c'était intéressant éventuellement
de changer et mettre un truc comme ça
peut-être pour le futur j'ai vu que
derrière il y a pas mal de de
jeux où ils ont fait ils ont pris ce
format d'ailleurs de double élimination
et je trouve que c'est vraiment
intéressant au début j'étais le premier
un petit peu à pas comprendre à dire
mais pourquoi deviner mais en fait ça
fait hyper sens quand on y pense parce
que
même moi je peux la France je sais pas
si vous l'avez suivi pour certains mais
quand on voit que jus de Moussard a
perdu au premier tour
alors pour moi c'était quand même un
défavoris de la compétition je me dis
bon tu fais une erreur tu es out je
comprends c'est
mais avec tous les élimination bah tu
perds une fois mais tu peux revenir et
tu as toujours une petite chance
et je trouve que c'est un compromis
intéressant comme tu gardes le côté
spectacle et tu gardes aussi la
possibilité de pouvoir revenir un peu et
avoir une chance quoi donc moi je trouve
que c'est c'est intéressant et après
pour avoir
bonjour à toi je suis sûr de ne pas voir
Laura commenter avec toi
bah Laurent il est regarde Laurent il
allait noir ici donc je pense que
Laurent si commentait avec moi en même
temps qui joue ça va être difficile pour
lui donc c'est pour ça qu'il n'est pas
là
c'est vraiment il est pas mal aussi
j'aime bien ouais oui il joue il joue
alors il a un pion isolé c'est vrai et
il a pas réussi pour l'instant obtenir
grand chose il y a ce petit problème sur
le fou aussi donc des fois il peut même
avoir du C4 audio 4 pour essayer de
profil du clouage mais Laurent a
toujours ce petit four en F3 qui qui
peut arriver mais avoir un C4 c'est
intéressant parce qu'après puis on prend
je te prends en fou
mais si je prends d'abord un F3
pour me débarrasser de mon fou et
maintenant pendant ces quatre moi j'ai
mon je m'attends en prison donc
après ces quatre il y a un petit
problème j'ai l'impression quand même la
position et il va falloir qu'il le règle
rapidement Laurent sinon ça va mal se
passer alors je vais voir si on a si on
récupère la caméra de Magnus et aussi
voir s'il est parti on commençait vous
savez ma liste est arrivé ça y est c'est
parti on a dû commencer je pense je vais
vérifier ça un petit seconde
et ouais donc on va est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on abandonne Laurent pour
partir voir
à Abdou c'est quand même le gros gros
gros match je pense de la Division 1 à
l'IRESA français contre abzottov pour
moi c'est vraiment le le très très gros
match et j'ai vraiment envie d'aller le
voir il y a eu à 14 et 8 donc je pense
que Laurent est content D8 et à plus le
problème sur la tour si jamais il y
avait eu la séquence avec C4 alors voir
on va aller voir mais par contre on
reste là quand même on va toujours
regarder les résultats vous savez des
des Français on ira avoir ah ça a pas
commencé encore
ça a pas commencé mais ça devrait
commencer vraiment
d'ici très peu de temps
ça n'a pas commencé encore
ok du coup je pense qu'on va rester sur
Laurent je vais juste
[Musique]
je vais juste la mettre à côté
par une page pour Laurent et une page
pour pas Laurent
voilà vous avez Laurent ici et dès que
ça tourne par contre on ira voir on va
donner on va donner priorité à la
Division 1
ça a pas commencé encore donc on peut
rester là dessus
donc il sait pas c'est quoi là depuis
donc il faut prendre cette froid
des 6
[Musique]
mangeant ses cinq à moins qu'il ait une
idée parce que vous savez qu'après la
capture en C5 et même vous avez plus
tard des coups comme tourner un C4 et on
peut créer de nouveaux un pion isolé ici
c'est ce qu'il a à faire donc soit tu
manges avec l'idée de réussir à tapes
sur des 5 soit tu manges pas quoi par
exemple la tour B1 la trompette est
aussi intéressante
il y a eu ici pour C5 mais c'est 5 et
tourbé 1 colonne ouverte pour les blancs
on va essayer de s'introduire ici et
Laurent qui qui souffre un peu dans
cette partie câlin rang qui souffre mais
s'il arrive à le tomber lui tu es
échanger des pièces ça peut être
intéressant pour B5 bien joué pression
sur les pions et permet de gagner la
colonne B en sont tombés
en 8 la dame aurait quand même pas mal
de de jeux sur les pions noirs qui sont
toujours un petit peu faibles le Caval
USA qui est toujours un peu en arrière
et des positions un peu difficile quand
même pour pour Laurent mais toujours
solide j'ai pas du tout clair tomber 8
salut Super Mario
j'espère que tu vas bien
ok je vérifie en même temps ça a pas
commencé de l'autre côté
non ça n'a pas commencé alors peut-être
que ça commence
après c'est la division la vie en deux
en fait j'ai pas eu de de
d'annonces à ce niveau là mais peut-être
que la division 1 commencera après la
division 2 ce qui m'a l'air étrange
parce que les gens sont tous arrivés
chez moi
à moins que
à moins que attendez parce que
ce n'est pas là
j'ai l'impression que les gens sont en
train de jouer
mais j'ai un doute
je vais
ce que vous savez que j'ai un petit j'ai
eu un souci une fois je vais raconter ce
qui se passe
ok en fait j'avais eu un problème il y a
quelques
il y a quelques mois quand j'avais
commandé un événement similaire et avec
mon compte stouf malheureusement j'ai
pas un compte qui est staff
et du coup ok ok ça joue donc en fait il
faut que je me connecte avec l'autre
compte les amis c'est normal je me suis
posé la question en fait je vois la
division 2 mais pas la 1 donc en fait ce
que je dois refaire c'est le doigt me
déconnecter de James com pour lancer
c'est comme de l'autre côté tout
simplement
donc je vais virer ça je vous enlever ça
vous enlevez la vue
et je vais déconnecter ici
parce que tu crois que mon compte elle
va malheureusement j'ai pas les j'ai pas
les droits
c'était bien spéciaux
normalement ça va le faire
et là je vais m'en occuper alors
ça marche pas
ok alors
quelques secondes là j'attends le mot de
passe
c'est vrai que si j'ai pas
ce compte je peux pas voir les parties
de la Division 1 heureusement qu'on
avait quand même Laurent qui
qui nous a
ok ça y est je suis connecté avec ce
compte là
[Musique]
et du coup on va partir
ici
et les parties sont
commencer par contre là de partir à côté
je vois pas la partie de la bio je pense
à se décalé c'est un décalé mais je vais
partir
c'est assez bizarre d'ailleurs allez hop
je crois que c'est décalé encore la
partie donc hop j'ai ça est-ce que vous
voyez toujours bien mon écran je suis
désolé pour le petit
pour le petit truc là petit problème hop
et je crois que n'est pas encore là
enfin ça n'a pas commencé et donc chez
Laurent vous avez encore
cette partie là qui est là donc on va
pouvoir suivre les deux en même temps on
a tout en même temps Laurent et on a
aussi
ça et chez qui on me dit qu'il n'est pas
coupé évidemment ça me change tout et
ouais moi j'avais tout préparé sur
l'autre sur l'autre
[Musique]
l'autre truc on va devoir changer un
petit peu tout ça
je vais vous changer
les chéquier
je vais vous le remettre un petit peu
droit
pour que vous puissiez voir un peu tout
ce qui se passe
bien et toutes mes selles sont mauvaises
les gens alors je suis désolé mais je
vais devoir changer un peu tout ça
j'avais préparé toutes les scènes
malheureusement sur
sur avec l'autre chéquier
l'autre compte on va dire
ça m'a tout remis
n'importe comment malheureusement
on va rester comme ça pour le moment
et
je vous mettrai les caméras et tout ce
que vous voulez
juste après la première partie comme ça
au moins j'aurai le temps de tout
refaire parce que là j'ai eu des petits
soucis techniques au niveau du compte
que
j'ai pas accès donc vous l'aurez vous
aurez tout la pose promis
donc pour l'instant la première partie
on va la faire sans échiquier Vincent
sans caméra sans rien sinon vous allez
voir qu'il y a tout qui va encore bouger
alors
donc c'est une partie celle là alors là
la structure on peut voir rapidement
G3 fougères
prise en C4 à 6
et à 4 donc il y a beaucoup de fois on
voit des pros cicatrices
à 4 empêche B5 puis on prend par exemple
j'avance un petit peu plus vite donc
dans cette position on voit que les
blancs ils vont jouer clairement sur une
case qui est importante c'est la casse
C5 avec une torrent C1 etc et du coup
vous voyez que la manette du cavalier
qui est intéressant de cavalier E5 pour
attaquer le fou et après revenir sur la
case D3 puis revenir sur la case c'est 5
ici donc hop et dans ces quatre donc
bien sûr ici les les noirs qui veulent
échanger les pièces et si jamais je
mange là pour jouer un jour cavalier D7
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas un coup comme
B6 qui pourrait être possible pour
chasser un peu ce cavalier en profitant
un peu que le contrôle aussi le pion
aussi
puis on racisme
donc c'est ce qu'on joue dans ce qu'on
joue avec trois ici
manus a commencé on va le voir on va
aller voir aussi
le reste
donc là on a la partie de laservana
c'est celle là donc c'est une belle
italienne
pour l'instant ces positions vous savez
on vous a eu un milliard de fois dans
notre vie
c'est je pense la partie pour l'instant
qui est pour nous le moins intéressant
alors des cas c'est un coup qui me qui
est malade un peu bizarre parce que
souvent en fait c'est un coup qu'on
prépare après la prise prise j'ai peur
que le pion en E4 soit un peu affaibli
un petit par exemple
prise et tout revu qui va devoir arriver
bientôt
ok
ca va les prendre dessin qui va
récupérer la pièce
et essayer de prétendre à l'égalité
peut-être
comme ça mais j'aime bien les blancs ici
j'ai une majorité centrale au centre 4
avec le fou qui est intéressant sur le
roi j'aime beaucoup les blancs ici je
sais pas ce qui va se passer c'est la
partie en tout cas
on va aller voir les parties un peu de
tout le monde malheureusement je suis
pas tout voir alors 45 on a cette
position
on a vu la jauge qui n'aimait pas trop
la potion de Magnus
prise vous aussi donc ça c'est théorique
il faut F5 H3 qu'a vallée des deux
par contre alors ça je connais pas du
tout il y a des positions qu'on peut
voir on a déjà vu d'ailleurs des
positions dans le match avec avec
[Musique]
Jules où il y avait eu du point froid
dans certaines variantes et la cavalier
prend bien sûr si je prends une pièce et
il va y avoir qu'elle va les prendre à 5
à cause du couloir si je prends la dame
il va y avoir foutran celui de cavaliers
5 qui perd un pion et en plus le roi il
est ouvert
et ici la jauge elle est pas contente du
tout à fait un point F1
qui a l'air quand même assez logique
alors si on a même pas
d'un point F1 qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire ici ça me ça m'a l'air ça m'a
l'air assez incroyable
[Musique]
les proposants pour un jambon dans 2700
Elo c'est pas un jambon un tabac
d'abeille je te le dis c'est pas du tout
un jambon ici donc on va prendre ou faut
F4 qui défend et qui empêche qu'elle va
les prendre mais bon non mais après
peut-être c'est une position qui
peut-être m'a venue à tes idées vous
savez là
il y a ce pion qui est toujours isolé il
y a un problème sur le pion des 5
et puis là des idées pour attaquer
peut-être un jour G5
et ramener des pierres peut-être j'ai
trois d'avoir
intéressantes pour les blancs donc
évidemment ça me paraît assez incroyable
de faire une qualité comme ça mais mais
ok en tout cas les noirs qui
réfléchissent depuis 3 minutes dans
cette position et Magnus qui qui est
bien alors je peux vous mettre si vous
voulez la la la
caméra malheureusement le temps il est
pas très bon donc je vais juste vous
mettre rapidement là le le
temps
je voudrais juste les temps
pour que
pour que vous voyez bien malheureusement
vous savez que j'avais à juste j'avais
tout fait mais malheureusement
je vois vraiment
je vous le fais comme ça en direct
désolé c'est pas très beau mais
en mode
studio je suis trop petit donc je vois
rien du tout
je vous la mets là
et celle de
amine oups
celle de
la mets comme ça aussi
et ça va être plus beau vous allez
pouvoir suivre un petit peu ça et toutes
les autres parties les caméras et tout
enfin les temps je vous les mettrai à
jour pendant la pause après la partie
et j'avais tout fait malheureusement
j'avais pas le bon kilo donc du coup ça
m'a tout refait à zéro c'est pas très
grave hop là vous avez quand même les
caméras des joueurs et je pense ça
intéressant de voir les caméras
d'urgence parce que
là ouais Magnus c'est 25e qualité
et c'est intéressant de de
voir un peu la tête que font les joueurs
pour un peu s'ils sont deg pas deck si
comment se passe un peu l'appartement
quel Caval est à 5 fou c'est de cavaler
C4
et maintenant madame est en peut arriver
un problème là-bas clair et la marche 3
enfin j'ai trois dommages 3 avec
éventuellement une tour qui peut s'y
couler sur la colonne âge c'est
intéressant en tout cas
et ouais
merci beaucoup connecte ton petit
message salut à tous salut Gaby
et
[Musique]
mvl bon ils sont pas du monde junior
c'était en Argentine d'ailleurs c'était
en 2010
ou 2009 2010 je crois
il a il a pas que ça dans son palmarès
du monde champion du monde de aussi
il a été
et encore beaucoup d'autres choses
ok est-ce qu'on peut aller voir la
partie de Abdou contre contre Hiro alors
je vais vous montrer un petit peu les
parties mais encore une fois les temps
vont pas être bon je vais vouloir faire
à la main
tout est calé je suis désolé mais je
vous la remets rapidement
et je vous remettrai le reste à la pause
hop je déconne un peu ici mais ça là ça
rend quelques secondes
je touche à la baguette maintenant
quelque chose
un petit peu par ici
et on a rien vu vous voyez toutes les
nickel
et rose ça va être la même
décaler ça c'est un cours si vous voulez
je suis un cours
que je fais
donc le temps vous avez le temps des
joueurs vous avez tout ce que vous
voulez en même temps et donc Abdou qui a
une position qui est qui a l'air assez
intéressante j'aime beaucoup en tout cas
sa position la colonne c'est on va avoir
un peu ce qui s'est passé rapidement
ok faux F4 3 donc ça c'est classique
tout ça qui va aller prendre qu'elle va
les prendre dans
trois cavaliers on sort les pièces tout
projet 3 et on joue c'est 5 donc là
c'est une position qui est symétrique au
niveau de la structure de pion
mais c'est vrai que les Blancs ont
l'avantage un peu d'espace là je suis
assez avec Madame tours manger à 7 et
c'est pas si c'est pas si évident pour
les Noirs j'apprécie quelques coups mais
c'est les Noirs je précisément et ben on
nous regarde tout de suite on comme ça
après symétrique par rapport à par
rapport en phase d'accord et ben les
pièces pour changer et peut-être les
noirs pour viser la nul
et pas la lune
c'est la partie
salut à tous
salut
à tous en tout cas si vous avez des
questions ou si vous voulez voir des
gens en spécifique
n'hésitez pas à me demander on peut le
voir si vous voulez on a aussi vous
savez de l'autre côté on a encore on a
encore Laurent qui joue on peut aller
voir Laurent avoir un peu ce que ce que
leur en fait
on a Laurent ici
il est moins il est moins bien mis mais
bon c'est Laurent
Laurent Cannet noir et Laurent qui qui
s'est créé un pion passé ici il y a
quand même beaucoup de chance de nuls
comme parchec d'un F5 je pense cette
partie contre drief cette ronde un va
finir en une
qui n'est pas mon résultat pour Laurent
qui avait les noirs et qui en plus avait
une position assez difficile dans cette
partie et voilà je sais d'un F5 si je
vais là je suis maintenant un coup donc
je ne peux pas venir ici si tu fais ça
il va me prendre ici donc j'ai pas eu
non plus envie donc ça va répéter ça va
faire nul et c'est obligatoire
et je retourne sur Abdou et Firo donc la
dame où est-ce que je la mets la dame
est-ce que je joue en cavalier C6
la B7
ça va
comment tu vas
tu vas
le price poule pour la compétition alors
le price poule je l'ai
mais je l'ai
mais je vais pas ici
je peux te dire ça je peux te dire ça
il y a 6 mois quelques clics je te dis
ça malheureusement je l'ai je l'ai pas
sur sur ici
oui je sais je me suis rendu compte
Nathan je sais que tu m'écoutes je crois
que je peux pas l'enlever
[Musique]
je m'arrêterai alors tac
les prix attendez
je cherche
effectivement
un petit truc petit tour de magie là
je sais pas comment faire
malheureusement je suis pas très malin
je suis pas très malin
non je suis pas mal je sais pas faire
parce que là j'ai ça là
non je sais pas faire désolé je parle
tout seul je parle à ma tante qui me
parle derrière
alors je vous dis pour les prix je suis
en train de chercher
mais je l'ai vu quelque part j'avais eu
un
truc dessus
les prix sont quelque part
et faire trop pas
les prix alors je peux pas vous les
affichez par contre je peux vous les
donner si vous voulez alors pour Laurent
qui est en deuxième division et ben le
fait d'être déjà ici
et après si il passe 9e 3500 7e 4000
5e 4005 4e 5000 troisième 6000 deuxième
7500 dollars et prenez la division 1
c'est 10000 dollars voilà ça c'est les
prix pour pour la division la Division 2
là vous savez tout maintenant
c'est un gros chèque après c'est un
tournoi qui dure 4 jours donc c'est
intéressant quand même pour savoir et la
division 1 les prix sont sont
beaucoup plus intéressants Laurent qui
qui a bien fait de pas commander son
Escom fr d'ailleurs
[Rires]
tout à l'heure on a demandé pourquoi il
était pas là ben écoute il joue et à son
niveau bah ça gagne bien la déchèques
quand on est bon aux échecs ça gagne pas
mal
malheureusement moi je ne partirai pas
comme ça moi généralement j'ai pas le
choix
[Rires]
j'ai pas le choix et d'ailleurs je
voulais je donne les résultats enfin les
prix pour le pour le la division 1 le
vainqueur c'est 30000 donc vous voyez un
système trois fois plus que que la
division 2 donc 30 000 20.000 au
deuxième 15e 125 au quatrième le
cinquième c'est 10000 et 7e donc c'est 5
5 6 1 10 000 et 7 8 700 5
donc en gros les derniers de Division 1
c'est égalité au deuxième la division de
cas et la division 3 il y a 32 joueurs
le premier prend 5 minutes 7 5000
premiers 36 2e
et après ça descend en 2008 2004 il y a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup de prix
aussi et le premier prix enfin je veux
dire le prix pour le dernier ainsi qu'à
1000 dollars donc comme intéressant on
voit deux enfants 5000 dollars dans
cette édition c'est quand même
intéressant pour un toit de de 4 jours
enfin cinq jours pardon 5 jours sur
internet ça reste quand même des des
groupes
qui nous qui nous parle depuis YouTube
salut à toi et bienvenue sur le stream
donc d'ailleurs pour ceux qui sont sur
Youtube n'hésitez pas à nous suivre vous
savez que vous avez le petit comment il
est d'ailleurs sur Youtube oups j'aurais
pu le chat que j'ai fait j'ai fait une
bêtise
je vois plus que tu fais une bêtise
vous avez en tout cas
la petite cloche pour vous abonner pour
vous abonner à la chaîne Youtube de
pièces comme fr n'hésitez pas en tout
cas à vous à vous abonner c'est gratuit
et puis nous ça nous soutient et puis
vous aussi ça vous permet de d'être à
chaque fois
au courant de tout ce qui se passe sur
sur YouTube dans les vidéos dans les
shorts ou même dans les dans les directs
donc n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre sur
twitch sur
sur Youtube
vous pouvez partager vous pouvez nous
suivre faire tout ce que vous voulez
être pas mal ici un frero qui a moins
fait un petit peu en B2
et qui arrive ici à acheter des pièces
donc j'ai l'impression que Kali Raisa
est en train de de se mettre bien alors
précarité
le cavalier en E5
c'est
à toi
texte en galère en plus tu vois que à
côté de mon nom sur sur Youtube et ben
j'ai une sorte de clé genre
que la molette quoi comme si moi j'étais
tech
alors comment il a le début
donc il y a eu on avait dit cavaler des
cinq la dame a bougé en B7 et après fou
et huit cinq on avait parlé tout à
l'heure les Noirs proposent un échange
de dames qui a été accepté par
par les Blancs et après maintenant il y
a le fou qui attaqué avec bien sûr tour
des deux qui aussi est une menace on
faut assise tour des deux avec les
jouets et surtout des un tour reprend B2
donc ça me coûte typique ou les blancs
sacrifient un pion pour avoir deux
colonnes ouvertes donc c'est ça
intéressant vous voyez que c'est un
genre qui a pas envie du tout comme tout
Robert pour que je passif ou même P4
pour avoir les pions qui sont plus tard
faibles en A3 ici il y a une tour D1
pour prendre vraiment de l'initiative
avec les Blancs pour combat 2 Faut B7 et
tour C7 donc là les blancs qui gagnent
vraiment l'initiative mais les noirs qui
grignote les pions
et qui continue le jeu de manière simple
donc moi j'aime bien la position
regarder de la merde d'être devant
l'ordinateur il s'en fout complètement
il a l'air d'être vraiment je pense
qu'il est quand même concentré mais il a
l'air d'être tranquille à la maison
donc avaler G6 attaque le cavalier le 5
et là la question qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de ce cavalier
parce que le défendre c'est quand même
très très moche car après qu'elle va les
prendre c'est très moche qu'elle va à
l'étranger si ça avec un le coup numéro
1 je prends après mon fou il pas
terrible certes
mais j'ai un peu plus avec les mains
tu as du mal à bouger un peu pour
l'instant mais bon j'ai encore une tour
qui peut les grignoter des pions
pas simple de commander blanc vont
réussir à les prendre puis on prend
fou bouge je mange là ça peut aussi être
intéressant et des fois ça pourrait être
un humain
c'est à dire que si j'ai mis les blancs
arrivent à manger là et plus tard avec
l'autre tour allait manger là etc donc
moi je mange je suis là ça va faire
égalité on a les périodes de même côté
la même fou et tout mais il faut encore
que les Blancs aillent manger des pions
ce que je trouve qu'il passait simple
car elle est propre ou F3 par exemple
qui empêche
à 5
parfois si tu vas pas comment je peux
défendre mon pion mais je peux toujours
continuer à attaquer l'option de
l'adversaire
mais bon je pense que les noirs sont
quand même pas mal dans la partie et
avoir le pion de plus avec les Noirs
c'est une sorte de contre-jeu par
rapport à l'activité des pièces blanches
qui sont quand même bien plus actifs que
des pièces noires même si la tour B2 est
quand même pas mal ici il faut
reconnaître
j'aime bien la position de d'aller
raisin cavalier F3
du coup il perd un temps dans tout ça et
les Noirs peut-être vont profiter pour
Jean foubet 5 ou 2
essayez de
parer le match du couloir continuer à
attaquer je sais pas intéressant
cavalier 7 c'est bête
je te pose la question ce sens pas bête
j'ai pas attendez 8 OK
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur cavalier SF
tu as mangé j'ai pas le choix je pense
prise et en fait peut-être que on s'en
fout de ce
matin quand même un petit coup de hache
ou cavalier
mais en fait ça va être menace en prise
prise caméra
si je fais un truc de style c'est quoi
le problème
ça et ça voilà
je sais pas je j'ai l'impression que tu
vois un position se fout en 8 c'est
quand même une mauvaise pièce des Noirs
je sais pas trop comment faire pour
l'instant donc c'est quand même dommage
de les changer et cavalier F3 je
comprends que les Blancs veuillent
garder leur cavalier mais bon
regardez les noirs et ben il prend des
pions ils prennent des pions tour à deux
est-ce que avaler contre fou tu arrives
à jouer cavalier noir qu'on peut fou je
pense ça va
mes cavaliers blancs contre foudoir ça
dépend en fait le
fouet une mauvaise pièce pas trop envie
de de garder cette pièce contre le
cavalier après si je mange des pions je
mange les pions ça va
mais
pas clair
pas clair du tout cette histoire
et bien sûr que les Blancs veulent pas
simplifier maintenant
qui arrive donc ça fait vraiment tout le
matériel si je mange là il se passe quoi
en fait
je fais ça je vais faire ça c'est quoi
la suite
je comprends pas trop
attention
un très joli mat
et je pense ce qu'il a calculé
a besoin de H6 direct et empêche le
cavalier G5 qui était
difficile et maintenant tourner 8 j'ai
toujours roi et fuite et on a
l'impression qu'on arrive à défendre
alors tour des luttes c'est intéressant
il y a il y a un clouage sur le fou sur
le fou et 8 mais il y a aussi une sorte
de de vis-à-vis donc ils ont de clouage
de deux côtés ou une découverte sur un
tour B8
et après tourner tu en as l'impression
que maintenant on a du mal à bouger
mais la question c'est qu'est-ce que tu
fais avec les Blancs
ça c'est pas possible là tu pars dans la
tour
manger là peut-être mais à un moment
donné tu vas être à court de
parce que par exemple
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que tes
pièces sont un peu à le placer au final
tu t'es un peu cloué tout seul peut-être
ça c'est un coup
difficile
avoir en tout cas attention les blancs
qui ont pris des risques pendant les
pions et à lire qui prend une petite
option à cette partie en plus avec le
temps 5 minutes 30 pour le noir contre
une minute pour les blancs donc la
cadence c'est 15 + 3 je vous le
rappellerai
il y a toujours un incrément mais
attention quand même que
attention que c'est pas encore c'est
clair du tout j'aime beaucoup la potion
est mort
en tout cas la situation quoi
moins bien mais pions de plus mais
autant vous voyez
soit on le coupe le fou tour mais
préférable oui c'est vrai mais j'ai
quand même un bouton de plus donc ça
change quand même pas mal pas mal de
choses et là apparemment il y a le carré
des quatre ça a été un raté on voit la
le petit signe du cavalier là
et apparemment il y avait un coup qui
était peut-être meilleur ici et qui
avait les décades du coup
je pense
c'est de colmater un petit peu la
position
vraiment ce que j'aurais joué alors du
coup firou qui qui est qui est mal parti
je crois s'il joue comme mogret ça va
pas le faire
ette B2 on va aller voir un peu les
parties on va aller voir un peu toutes
les toutes les parties ici qui avait les
best encore du coup cavalier des 5 m'a
l'air pas mal
à moins qu'il y a une menace cachée
je ne vois pas
avec les Blancs bon ça va alors bonne
augure du coup pour filou
en tout cas Abdou est fidèle les deux
hein les deux joueurs sont hyper
offensifs mais c'est vrai que dans cette
dans cette position
a du mal quand même à être plus offensif
que ça il a une seule pièce qui joue
mais c'est un pion de plus donc là
attention moi j'aime bien cavalier
peut-être faire un peu le ménage pour
prendre ton point qu'elle va les prendre
on reprend et peut-être et sortir le roi
et me dire que bon voilà c'est ce qui
fait donc quand on prend qu'elle va les
prendre la roi c'est oui moi j'aime bien
ça permet de
se déclouer attaquer le cavalier et
quand elle est bouche d'ailleurs il y a
ça en est
c'est la partie
et là on peut imaginer une prise en 7
comme ça peut-être
sûrement d'ailleurs
je prends ici et je raconte en plus hein
ce que j'avais dit au début j'avais dit
que
les blancs peuvent toujours avoir des
idées pour manger depuis un 7 mais qu'au
final un pion c'est un pion et que
Firo a une boisson quand même très très
solide et après faut prendre pour
reprendre donc peut-être il peut même je
roi des 7 les pièces sont un petit peu
vous voyez un peu mal placé
sur roi des 7 j'ai encore tout échec là
et si on reprend je prends le fou donc
tu peux le sel là avoir le roi actif et
puis en qui avance c'est ce qui se passe
il aurait pas aussi manger directement
cavalier mais s'il allait manger comme
ça le roi rêve le roi avait un E7 et la
tour en 6 donc là du coup regardez il a
bien dégagé le roi blanc pour le mettre
out de l'échiquier et maintenant il va
commencer à pousser le petit pion de
merde
je pense que la potion gagnante qu'un
tour à 7 d'ailleurs très bien joué qui
garde ici et qui permet la tour derrière
le pion pour pousser l'option je pense
que c'est Spirou qui valait cette partie
je pense que c'est c'est quelqu'un
gagnant ça il y a un pion plus trop
actif
puis on passait le roi blanc est trop
loin
faire ce qu'il veut mais allez
3 B4 c'est toujours tombé 7 dès que tu
arrives à 140
et le pire c'est que sur toi et chaque
du coup là du coup roi qui peut partir
où il veut on pousse c'est juste terminé
maintenant qui appartient en CA le pion
qui va partir comme ça et le roi qui va
arriver en C2 pour déloger la tour B1 et
faire
et faire nul donc là du coup à Féro qui
a fait une très bonne partie défensive
mais Abdou qui c'est vrai on a beaucoup
voulu et après beaucoup de risques dans
cette partie et salut à toi super
looping bienvenue sur le stream ça fait
un bail que je t'ai pas vu j'espère que
tu vas bien en tout cas
et ouais qui est parti la partie qui
continue incroyable
ah oui vous savez qu'en fait nous on a
on a 30 minutes on a 30 secondes enfin
pardon on a une minute de délai sur le
tournoi on voyait la caméra qui était
parti
mais il y a un délai en fait dans les
parties online on a une minute de délai
je me disais le mec qui était parti il
joue il veut son iPad depuis la cuisine
et ben non
tour des 8 3 là et le pion qui avance ça
va être abandon
donc j'ai plein de résultats si vous
voulez j'ai aussi Caravana lazavik qui a
fait nul et ceux qui a battu et game of
et Spirou qui vient de gagner contre
contre abstance
Carlson qui a des blancs on va aller
voir rapidement Magnus qui nous fait un
Magnus elle est blanche dans cette
partie je vais revenir avec les coups on
va revenir
à la position finale après on pourra
avoir un bon ce qui s'est passé trois
quatre trois quatre à trois puis on pour
la pièce pour les Noirs la position elle
est difficile
oui on va vraiment que
les blancs d'une pièce de plus mais ce
fou en D1 il est extrêmement mauvais
tous les pions sont case blanche et
j'arrive pas à passer
important et là attention que si le noir
joue B3
ben il y a plusieurs thèmes intéressants
déjà le fou jouera plus après B3
plus tard suivi de prise et B2 si jamais
le fou blanc partait quelque part
plein de thèmes comme ça parce que moi
je pense du coup vraiment on va faire à
5 pour mettre le four en 4 et pour
passer en C6 et en décembre tout ça mais
après à 5 Gb3 le foot passera plus
et ben écoute j'aime bien les noirs
parce que les pièces jouent pas j'ai
trois pions pour la pièce mais le foot
est vraiment passif vous tellement nul
que peut-être que c'est pas grave du
tout pour les noirs
après matériellement trois pions c'est
trois points il y a un fou c'est 3
points aussi donc matériellement les
noirs sont pas du tout en retard même si
on préfère recevoir une pièce de plus
quand même
j'avais pas du tout vu
et mes trois ça ouvre ça donne ça fait
un cadeau le pion C3 mais donc un
quatrième pion mais il veut quand même
réussi à ouvrir les cases blanches et
faire des choses donc que se passe-t-il
ici
là je mange un peu gratuit
il a mangé le pion d'ailleurs c'est pas
bon quoi apparemment c'était pas un bon
coup du tout de la part de de amine avec
les Noirs roi F4 aurait été le meilleur
en fait pour passer le roi comme ça et
garder la structure intacte qu'est-ce
qu'on fait je prends là
j'ai quatre pions pour la pièce mais
c'est vrai que les pions sont plus
connectés maintenant j'ai plus mes pions
qui avancent ensemble maintenant j'ai
que des pions isolés et le Noir ont du
mal à avancer
je pourrais jamais faire ces deux
et du coup peut-être que maintenant
Magnus a une chance de faire quelque
chose à regarder un fou de fou prends
ici et comment ça aurait été un petit
peu les pions l'adversaire
va arriver un jour
bref 4 à 5 pour pas partir
et en fait ça va être nul parce que le
pion g va être échangé quand je veux
avec H5
et sur là on va toujours réussir à le
manger aussi donc il y a pas trop de cas
c'est ça on pourra regarder un petit peu
après ce qui se passait
donc
il y a plus grand chose
à faire alors les plans ont toujours un
petit peu mal au niveau de placement des
pièces vous voyez le fou contrôle
vraiment le cavalier
Eric pas bouger pour l'instant il faut
prendre ces quatre restes un coup mais
je prends quand je veux
et quand je mange là je perds le pion en
G et après il y a deux semaines donc tu
as pas envie et le roi qui part par
là-bas mais je pense qu'il va faire
là-bas
peut-être que c'est devenu Magnus qui
veut gagner la devise qui est pas avec
son roi de l'autre côté et attention on
voit qu'il y a révisé et puis H qui
maintenant avancé
H5
et maintenant il y a des pions de
partout attention à la fourchette je
sais pas si c'est important je sais pas
c'est la fourchette elle est elle est
grave ou pas
mais j'ai l'impression que cavalier D3
est une menace quand même il y a une
des quatre qui part la fourchette
et là c'est compliqué les noirs qui ont
beaucoup de mal à placer leur truc
placer leur pièce mais quand même c'est
vrai que le pion qui peut avancer sa vie
quand même
pas si facile
cette cavalue c'est le meilleur coup
c'est pas vrai que la roi E2 sans qui
c'est deux mais bon
[Musique]
c'est chaud
voilà il a pris ce cette position et
après
je pense
il va attendre on va mettre le four
peut pas passer je crois pas les moyens
de passer
si je passe par là
là il faut attendre
allez voilà je pense à
ouf là je pense c'est
nulle
attention miroir bien
un petit truc qui a un béton c'est que
ce roi là et sur rois
je peux pas contrôler à la fois cette
case là
par ici
mais bon je pense que le roi blanc ferme
tout le temps dès que le roi noir passe
ici il y aura
et dès que je passe ici il y aura voilà
et là il va et là il va attendre je
pense en fait c'est nul c'est nul mais
mais ouais pas faire grand chose là une
pièce de plus mais trois pions
qui avance
tout est nul apparemment salut
à toi
qui a une très belle
qualité de chez lui
il est bien il est bien
fou c'est 5
rois des trois
on va attendre ça va faire nul
et du coup dans ces petits matchs et ben
on a pour l'instant kerwana et Magnus je
pense donc
Magnus qui joue contre Tabata Bay qui
vont faire nul et on a eu deux résultats
décisifs avec fil rouge là qui a battu
avec les noirs
et ce Wesley qui a battu avec les plans
Pavel el yalov avec sa petite italienne
va revenir en cette cavalier il est
blanc comme pas gagner ça c'est
impossible de gagner ça pour les joueurs
qui qui
la salle
donc je vous rappelle qu'on a une petite
minute de décalage avec elle
et puis on attend on attend on attend on
attend on attend
ait
une petite pause d'environ 5 minutes
pour la deuxième partie je vais voir si
Laurent a fait l'autre partie pendant ce
temps là
je sais pas s'il y a moyen de voir ça
Laurent
il allait blanc donc voilà ce qu'on va
faire je vais
je vais vous laisser une petite pub
parce que je dois vous mettre des pubs
vous avez comment ça marche cet
événement
5 minutes et vous savez qu'en plus il
faut que j'actualise des certaines
petites choses sur l'Obs donc je vous
dis à tout de suite et restez parmi nous
de partez pas on revient enfin je
reviens d'ici
quelques minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier sur
perd du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speechess ou les
titles
il se déroulent en présentiel ou en
ligne vivez comprenez en direct les
parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition aux
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour enfin je suis de
retour en France je suis tout seul
donc je suis de retour pour cette
deuxième rond donc là j'ai réussi à
ajouter tout ce que je voulais ajuster
donc je vais vous mettre maintenant la
partie de Magnus qui a commencé enfin
qui va commencer dans un instant donc
Magnus aura les Noirs voici contre Abdou
contre
je dis n'importe quoi
et hop
donc à côté je veux pas vous je vais pas
vous vous spoil mais on a on a Laurent
Freyssinet qui est venu à Abou de treef
dans sa partie de colorant qui est
qualifié pour
pour je crois que c'est le 8e de finale
de sa poule
nous sommes de retour généralement
plus cher à revenir mais mais du coup
elle a juste tout seul aujourd'hui parce
que Laurent et ben Laurent est occupé à
battre drief c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je suis tout seul aujourd'hui donc
petite anglaise de la part de tabacabay
avec les Blancs contre contre Magnus
et ok on laisse tranquille
voir comment ici le Magnus va jouer
cette position c'est un coup qui est
souvent utilisé avec l'idée de lire un
jour sur la case
des quatre cavaliers donc c'est un coup
un petit peu fantaisie quand même
cavalier cavalier H6 c'est pas un coup
qu'on voit tous les jours
dans une partie d'échec
mais c'est vraiment de venir
attaquer le centre et empêcher un jour
une poussée de 4
donc là il y a beaucoup de de
possibilités et je pense que ça va ta
belle en fait là il sera en fait de ses
devoir laquelle jouer contre Magnus
parce que je dis s'il n'est pas en
théorie et sur le site
ok je vais faire un petit test Nathan si
tu m'écoutes encore
est-ce que ça va mieux
donc
sur YouTube
qui est
Anthony salut à tous
je change un petit peu un truc
[Musique]
donc là il y avait un truc assez
intéressant de la part de
tabac Tabe a eu un HK alors souvent sur
H4 la réponse des Noirs c'est de faire
H5 pour empêcher le pion d'avancer vous
voyez mais après H4 maintenant les noirs
peuvent plus faire à chaque à cause du
cavalier en H6 donc il y a eu B6 H5 B7
bien sûr quand je prends là au moins h
pour que la tour et le défendre le
cavalier H6 c'est important ici salut va
voir le score actuel c'est nul nul il y
a eu une seule partie je vais vous
rajouter le score si vous si vous voulez
faire ça parce que j'ai un petit truc
[Musique]
alors je vois
il est ici de ce corps
score des joueurs est là
ok alors fou B7 et là du coup Thomas qui
réfléchit
c'est pas grand chose genre je prends
donc là généralement la solution ah je
pense elle va aider à empêcher avec les
noirs de faire
ici il y aura h 30 il faut prendre 6 la
tour doit rester en H8 pour défendre
lequel elle est et c'est pour ça que
grâce à 4h5 de la part des blancs et ben
Magnus pourra pas faire petit rock de
suite et donc là on peut imaginer d'être
un des 6 Dame des 7 pour pour commencer
et voir après ce qu'il a envie de faire
rock ou pas dans tous les cas il y a 10
ans qui va être prise soit je ferai
grand rock qui marque quand même assez
assez
difficile à faire soit tout simplement
Caval F5 est plus tard on pourra faire
le petit rock parce que attrapé en pince
peut-être des six pour commencer à la
Croate ici
après n'hésitez pas sur le chat si vous
si vous avez des questions par rapport
aux parties si vous avez des
parties que vous voulez voir en
particulier donc suivre la division 1
donc les matchs qu'on a on a
tabatabase on a aussi
Furious Jack on a besoin de
donc c'est les quarts de finale donc de
l'air sings grandsestour
et c'est la division 1 donc on a trois
divisions une division avec 8 joueurs
une division avec 16 joueurs et une
division avec 32 joueurs et c'est notre
bisou
bienvenue à tous en tout cas tous ceux
qui nous qui nous rejoignent sur le sur
le stream
et n'hésitez pas à me solliciter pour
pour
donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas alors fil
rouge on va aller voir ce que c'est mais
pour l'instant ça vient juste de
commencer même pas regardé il a même pas
encore joué un coup alors pour l'instant
Ali resa il a gagné la fin de partie
donc il est pas mal
cette partie de elianov contre sauce
c'est une sorte d'anglaise un peu
similaire on va pas s'attarder trop et
carvana lavix ça a fait nul aussi et là
encore une fois une sorte une sorte
d'Espagnoles avec les Blancs d'échanges
qui a été faite ici donc position assez
intéressante il y a plein d'idées dans
ces positions et karena qui a fait match
nul avec les Noirs lors de la première
partie va essayer de mettre la pression
sur l'azalik pour gagner avec les Blancs
lors de cette deuxième partie
donc je vous propose de retourner sur
Magnus pour l'instant c'est la partie
qui a le plus avancé
tandis que firou ça à peine commencé il
y a eu des quatre un seul coup donc on
va un petit peu attendre et là dans la
partie de
tabatamer Magnus et au final
dans cette pression sur le cavalier H6
et après à
h63 donc là intéressant vous êtes le
foot sur gâteau généralement on le donne
pas généralement c'est la pièce la plus
importante des Noirs mais après la prise
ici et ben j'imagine que l'idée de
Magnus le son casque blanche avec D6
peut-être dame D7 et voir un petit peu
[Musique]
voir un petit peu
comment se fout F4 va jouer vraiment
l'idée c'est de jouer sur casque blanche
ça même ça vous voyez un peu fou ce fou
qui peut être un peu fermé d'ailleurs
c'est le fou n'arrive pas à être actif
vous voyez par exemple après un coup
comme Daisy de 5 par exemple ce Foussier
en temps des deux bah il est pas très
bon quoi c'est faux donc l'idée de
donner un Focas noir plus tard c'est de
jouer sur la couleur opposée chacun
jouant sans sa couleur donc là j'ai 15
ans donc les blancs vont jouer sur casse
blanche ça paraît assez logique
salut à tous salut zencaro
bienvenue à tous donc à reprise prise en
Magnus qui
réfléchit est à la tablette qui a l'air
très très motivé en tout cas on voit un
grand cancérieux de du genre avec les
Blancs
cette partie
et ici je sais pas comment on va
continuer à l'air intéressant
j'ai pas trop ce qu'il est possible de
faire moi j'aime bien aussi
mais en fait là je crois que depuis tout
à l'heure je vous dis n'importe quoi il
me semble que je vous dis n'importe quoi
parce qu'après des sites qu'il y a G4
qui va
qui va perdre de cavaliers après ça ça
va aller ben il est il est pas bon ça
manque que je fasse E5 de justesse pour
revenir avec une Cabaye en recette mais
bon ça a pas l'air génial tout ça donc
Magnus il est pas comme moi il est pas
il est pas comme moi dans des pièces en
un coup dans chaque partie donc il va
trouver de meilleures solutions que de 6
mais un coup de si c'est un coup normal
dans la position malheureusement
je pense que malgré il est pas content
je pense qu'il a dû manger cette roi
sans penser que ce cahier est plus de
cases peut-être qu'il a oublié ce qu'il
y avait des petites cases un peu comme
moi j'ai oublié aussi je sais pas s'il
est il est capable de faire des blender
les mêmes blender que moi ça
m'étonnerait mais why not
donc là du coup c'est compliqué de
devoir
votre cavalier
si justement c'est l'inverse qu'on doit
faire je vous rappelle tout à l'heure on
a avec les Blancs la paire de fou contre
un seul fou de case blanche chez les
Noirs les Blancs doivent juste sur case
enfin ouvrez la case blanche pour jouer
sur avec ce foutaisement E6 pour jouer
voyez les cases noires sont tout tout
ouvert ça serait vraiment très très
difficile pour pour les noirs de jeux
d'Ariane avec tout ça et uf-6 de la part
de Magnus
et l'idée c'est quoi son G4 le jeu
comment
le jeu de 5
E
[Musique]
on voit très bien à son body language
de fou le centre et une position qui
calme très très intéressante pour eux
imaginer un four aux trois pour jouer F4
il a pas l'air content
il a pris mauvaise décision pour
l'instant cette partie et je pense que
la canton de Blender le 4 je pense qu'il
a oublié et je pense qu'il a oublié les
conséquences de
ce que vous pensez trop en anglais il
pensait qu'il peut être le décès
derrière elle a dû oublier que
cavalier pas de cases après F5
et c'est très difficile
c'est très difficile est-ce qu'on mange
en D6 et on se dit bon bah tu as le
structure dégueulasse
mais peut-être que maintenant on peut
comme mater vous voyez avec nos pièces
comme ça ça a pas l'air très joli
peut-être un peu colmater
peut-être que juste il a mangé des 6
il a mangé des 6
et maintenant peut-être un cavalent en
dessin que ça prend une bonne idée
d'être un petit keV Adama
F5 connu de G4 est connu pour être
risqué par les Noirs
l'idée de cavalage 6 à 5 de 4 c'est
quand même hyper connu mais je pense que
Magnus a très très mal j'ai réalisé
cette
suite de quoi il y a eu h64 je pense
qu'il a complètement halluciné parce que
c'est quand même pas dans son dans ses
habitudes
de rater une partie autant
et là c'est quand même difficile pour
lire
est-ce que les gens ont le droit d'avoir
un onglet avec la tête des joueurs alors
justement oui les joueurs peuvent se
voir s'ils le souhaitent
ça c'est clair en fait ils sont sur un
zoom tous et je crois que tu peux ouvrir
la tête enfin la caméra
c'est comme une vraie partie en fait tu
peux le voir et donc du coup souvent on
voit enfin partie les joueurs se
regardent un peu ce jauge un petit peu
de H3 comme j'avais proposé
et je crois que c'est
je crois que c'est c'est permis
pour l'instant pour l'instant
[Musique]
les dégustes
on va dire pas sur le site qui est
pas très bien pour ma goutte ici donc
attention par contre F4 c'est un coin
intéressant F4 c'est un coup que qu'on
peut avoir envie de jouer d'un côté
parce qu'en fait en jouant F4 ici et ben
j'ai plus qu'à Valier F4 voyez
donc en fait
c'est intéressant j'ai plus qu'à valider
F4 donc soit on fait cavalier F4 on n'a
pas F4 sans fait F4 donc c'est vraiment
un coin intéressant il veut laisser à
son adversaire le droit de faire des
choix et du coup de se tromper et dans
vos parties c'est pareil quand vous
jouez un joueur généralement qui est mon
fort que vous et que la position en
l'air à peu près égale laissez un
adversaire laissez-le faire des choix
parce que ça c'est à ce moment-là qui
peut se tromper si à chaque fois dans la
partie vous forcez des choses vous
essayez d'échanger des pièces faites des
menaces il y a toujours un seul coup
possible etc bah au final adversaire va
pas faire de mauvais coup et dans vos
parties souvent vous avez besoin de
forcer l'adversaire à faire des erreurs
donc laissez-le jouer faites des petits
plans des idées mais surtout laisser
votre adversaire faire des
erreurs là j'aime beaucoup les lettres
cavaliers
parce qu'en fait le plan des blancs à ce
qu'on fait ça on va trouver ça
franchement pour moi c'est pas clair moi
je suis en train de jauger lequel est le
mieux et
c'est pour moi pas clair du tout en tout
cas
ok donc dame aussi avec les jouets et là
du coup Magnus qui se prépare à faire
petit rock ou grand rock moi c'est pas
encore en tout cas manuel joue vite
c'est un truc qui est clair je joue très
vite parce que comme il est pas bien bah
il est cédé de
d'avoir un contre-jour quelque part il
fait pas de ma valeur quand même un peu
trop osé bien évidemment avec les
recoposés et les colonnes A et B qui
s'ouvrait très très vite donc ici petit
Roc est bien F5 c'est peut-être aussi
une possibilité même si j'aime pas trop
F5 pour vous dire la vérité alors
pourquoi j'aime pas les 5 parce que bon
là il y a un vis-à-vis donc c'est encore
pire même sans vis-à-vis j'aime pas
parce qu'en fait
après l'échange d'ici l'échange des fous
et bah le cavalier 5 aura personne pour
le chasser alors qu'il sèche à quoi tu
vas voir il faut prendre 5
donc du coup j'aime pas trop changer les
fous pour l'instant parce que j'ai
l'impression que les Blancs auront accès
trop facilement la classe des hommes
tout là
et ma petite continue à jouer vite
dans une position
difficile quand même pour pour amine
donc la 4 à 5 très logique si je vois ça
que moi même le pion B va être faible
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup la position de
de tabac Tabe franchement je trouve
qu'il fait une grosse partie
c'est top
pour l'instant ça va être dur de passer
de passer GM maintenant
en tout cas pas dans mes intentions je
sais pas si bon laisser de la rincer
blender je valide le concept c'est comme
ça que je massacre à chaque fois
mais c'est comme ça nos parties c'est
toujours pareil tu le sais très bien
on joue au hasard jusqu'à être mal et
gagner autant c'est c'est vraiment
[Musique]
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut faire moi
tout doucement dans les pas compte
à quel point grand maître c'est un autre
niveau
faut mettre un bon et demi qu'un mauvais
GM ok je suis quand même pas d'accord
enfin ok un bon ami c'est quoi c'est
1500 un mauvais GM ouais c'est un GM qui
a 2003 quoi
ou peut-être encore enfin je sais pas
un vieux GM plutôt mais en fait non mais
grand maître vous rendez pas compte
c'est un niveau qui qui est beaucoup
trop fort en fait
donc là actuellement on m'a plein quand
même ça nous arrive enfin moi ça
m'arrive de temps en temps de battre
quand même
mais de là à l'être c'est encore un
autre niveau c'est autre chose vous
vendez pas compte grand maître c'est
pour moi qui travaille pas assez des
échecs non je sais que l'investissement
est beaucoup trop important et je ne le
saurai pas en tout cas pas de suite
mais
ce qui parlait de lui-même
ah ok ok ok oui c'était l'entraîneur de
tous les meilleurs du monde à l'époque
notamment de
youssouphouf qui
un de mes mec on va dire de m'aider mais
genre préféré hein
et du coup et devant ce qui était comme
un international mais tu es un très très
bon maintenant peut-être même le
meilleur de l'époque
voilà
tout fait prof c'est un médecin plein
temps ouais j'ai pas j'ai pas le temps
mais j'ai pas envie quand vous
travaillez dans un truc vous avez moins
de motivation c'est clair et après
passer du temps
c'est quand même être c'est quelque
chose de difficile la mettre c'était
vraiment un objectif que je m'étais fixé
parce que j'étais quand même pas loin
depuis longtemps par contre grand maître
ça reste quand même quelque chose de
ultra difficile quand même vous vous
rendez pas compte quand même c'est en
France on a quand même des remettre en
France est-ce que tu peux nous le dire
ou peut-être ciel bleu qui est là bien
informé sur tout ça
c'est quoi des stats des maîtres et
grand maître en France par exemple là
vous allez comprendre à quel point
à quel point c'est dur
faire des grands maîtres dans le monde
je sais pas combien il y en a mais dans
le monde il y en a pas beaucoup
[Musique]
je crois dans le monde des camps il y en
a il y en a moins de 1000
dans le monde
peut-être plus quand même
pas tant que ça
j'étais jeune pas déjà mis en France ah
ouais bon c'est plus dur 53 et demi
53 GM pardon 1100 grands mètres dans le
monde bah vous voyez un séchoir il y a
combien de joueurs d'échec dans le monde
et seulement 1100 m enfin c'est
trop dur c'est pas à mon âge qu'on
travaille pour être grand maître
généralement tu le sais qu'on est plus
jeune quand même
tu le sais quand tu es plus jeune quand
même
pas maintenant de plus en plus tu passes
quand même avant 18 ans quoi après ça
veut rien dire tu peux faire passer
grand-mère mais ok moi j'ai 2400 hello
quoi
les 100 points qui manquent pour passer
grand maître vous vous rendez pas compte
mais c'est
c'est immense
c'est immense et j'ai pas le niveau pour
1742 grande Master et 1315
ok merci pour vos chiffres mais oui non
c'est c'est
énorme c'est énorme donc
c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué alors
là il s'est passé plein de choses tout à
l'heure alors on parle en parlant pas et
on rate l'essentiel quand même je pense
que vous n'êtes pas venu ici pour qu'on
parle de de mon élo plutôt parler un
petit peu de parties de tabataveil et de
caresses donc Magnus qui est encore en
train de souffrir mais il se bat bien
quoi c'est pas très bien Magnus
et essayer de changer les tours gagner
la colonne
intéressant
bon on est le champ en dessous du miga
merci de me l'avoir
rappelé youmé être grand maître
[Musique]
si tu me dis bien tu passes grand maître
bah je sais pas tu as
tant d'argent autant de trucs voilà et
ben ok ça peut être une motivation
supplémentaire mais là travailler comme
un comme un taré pour pour devenir grand
maître moi actuellement maintenant ça va
pas me porter grand chose donc ben je
m'en fous tout simplement c'est pas du
tout ce que je recherche après oui tu me
donnes un sponsor qui me dit tiens vas-y
va jouer
de l'argent pendant que tu essayes bah
ok peut-être que je peux y arriver mais
encore c'est beaucoup de travail
extrêmement dur mais là maintenant en
travaillant parce que vous voulez que je
fasse c'est impossible quoi
totalement impossible
avec un sponsor en plus même ça il y
aurait peu de chance que j'y arrive je
pense je pense pas avoir le talent
nécessaire pour pour être grand maître
j'essaie d'être honnête avec vous
je me trompe peut-être mais je veux être
avec vous
très grand maître il doit y avoir top
quand même
pour les gens à plus de 2007
mais
septembre
j'aime beaucoup la position des blancs
mais Magnus quand même ta position elle
tient à pas grand chose c'est-à-dire que
si tu avais les boules il y a ça en
l'air peut-être que j'ai ça qui peut
arriver ou ça qui peut arriver fous
c'est 6 tout se protège bien
par comparaison je connais très peu de
gens qui font un doctoration oui bon le
problème
en fait les gens ils s'en foutent quoi
ils s'en foutent que donc
il y a pas de tout ça
il y a pas
et je crois que c'est
au Japon il me semble
si je compare un peu le le goût avec les
échecs alors je vais peut-être me faire
engueuler dans le chat si c'est des
bêtises dites-moi et je crois que au
Japon si tu passes professionnelles
et ben tu as Insee et après tu passes
donc tu commences à être professionnel
tu as les Danes etc il me semble que
quand tu passes pro au Japon et ben tu
as une sorte de retraite à vie en fait
il me semble que
que ce qui passe pro tu as de l'argent
que tu vas tomber tous les mois tout le
temps
ça te permet de pouvoir vivre de ta
passion et continuer à progresser et à
t'entraîner je crois que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe alors peut-être que j'ai
des bêtises il me semble que j'avais
entendu ça en tout cas et aux échecs ben
si on me dit bah tiens vas-y tu parles
quand même on donne de l'argent à vie
une retraite je sais pas même 1000 euros
quoi
ben ok ça fait réfléchir quoi est-ce que
je est-ce que je je
fais l'effort pour être un maître là du
coup c'est un truc qui peut être
intéressant vous voyez donc en fait en
fait
tout ça c'est intéressant il y a plein
de choses mais le problème qui fait des
chèques et ben c'est pas populaire
donc
[Musique]
voilà c'est comme 5 millions et que tu
hésites toujours ouais bah
c'est dans le chat il y en a qui ont 5
millions à donner n'hésitez pas
et que c'est bien pour les malades on
avait fait à l'époque quand j'habitais à
Nice et ben on avait fait
comment ça s'appelle il y avait eu un
une expérience qui avait été faite avec
IBM et et là fédération et on avait fait
un match France - Russie et en fait elle
avait des capteurs c'est un match pour
la personne âgées qui est vraiment 70
ans et plus et elle capteur pour voir si
les chèques aidé
pour Alzheimer etc et en fait si vous
réfléchissez donc surtout pour le genre
d'échec qui sont dans des clubs etc
est-ce que vous connaissez dans le chat
des gens d'échec
qui ont Alzheimer
donc moi je suis dans les échec depuis
très longtemps ça fait plein de clubs
et je n'ai jamais vu une personne âgée à
avoir à avoir Alzheimer
voilà donc je pense que l'échec
clairement
clairement c'est ça aide pour Alzheimer
moi je voyais des personnages qui
avaient 90 ans
qui était très bien encore dans la tête
et grâce aux échec je pense aussi
que ça aide vachement à tout ça
c'est complètement raté les trucs parti
on va aller voir si vous voulez
rapidement à lire ça
on peut le voir si vous voulez c'est
parti
ici on a complètement raté un peu leur
partie et les raisins qui a des blancs 3
4 5 6 et une position qui a l'air d'être
clairement avantageuse en tout cas je
vais vous changer
je vais vous mettre le score
des joueurs
mais
t'en va très très peu enfin vraiment je
trouve que c'est ouf en fait
je rapidement je vais vous faire la
l'automatique tescom voir comment on
arrive là
qui a gagné à la première partie si
gagne celle-là c'est quasiment plié
parce que alors tu as quatre parties je
vous rappelle
et gagner 2-0 déjà c'est pas mal non
après il y a des joueurs qui sont plus
résistants que d'autres à tout ça il y a
un joueur qui habite en Espagne aux
Canaries c'est un joueur qui est qui est
quel pays il est
croate
je crois qu'il est croître bosniaque
tout ce qu'il est un grand maître
un grand maître qui a 2500 hello et il a
cette année 80 ans
et continue à jouer à son meilleur
niveau enfin son mari peut-être pas mais
il continue à se maintenir à 2500 €
c'est ouf
et ce joueur des années que je le joue
les années que je me dis bon c'est bon
maintenant
je vais me battre maintenant j'arrive
pas il est trop fort quand même trop
fort
trop fort et
[Musique]
corseille aussi
c'était quoi c'était
un match
contre
comment il s'appelait son port du monde
vétéran français qui était
vicer il y avait un il y avait eu un
match organisé entre les deux joueurs
pour un festival de Cannes et c'était
hyper impressionnant c'était hyper
impressionnant ah non il est pas vieux
Amandine à 45 ans
quand même plus que ça quel âge
cinquantaine je pense qu'il a pas 25 ans
[Musique]
mais
ouais je l'avais vu mais le jour que je
vous dis s'appelle courage Ikea je vous
l'ai fait dans la classe si vous voulez
je crois que c'est comme ça
et
je sais pas si c'est un cas à la fin
mais je trouve qu'il est il est trop
impressionnant parce qu'il a 2500
peut-être actuellement il doit être à 80
mais récemment il a baissé
en plus j'ai 1000 fois mais
c'est très très impressionnant très
impatiente
et quand tu vois que son topello c'est
quasiment 2006 et que toute sa vie il a
eu 25 50 maintenant 80 ans il est encore
à 2500 hello et pourtant il joue
beaucoup il est très actif il est très
actif et tout le temps et
le pire c'est que quand il y a double
ronde c'est des fois tu fais double
ronde tu es fatigué te parti par jour
qui dure 5-6 heures tu dis bon allez à
la comédie on fait nul on va se reposer
un petit peu etc bah lui 80 ans rien à
moi je joue pas faire nul quoi il
est très compatible très combatif enfin
je le trouve vraiment
trouve vraiment
[Musique]
impressionnant en tout cas
vous allez voir le portage de joueur
d'échec avec des membres de régulation
ouais c'est clair mais de manière
générale c'est vrai que que
[Musique]
ça marche en fait je suis sûr que
l'échec ça aide à
avant je pense que la personne OK
[Musique]
mais bon même ça me casse comme ça ça
reste beaucoup
mais oui c'est clair que je pense que
l'échec ça aide à combattre l'Alzheimer
encore une fois je connais personne qui
Alzheimer en jouant d'échec et quand je
dise voir des chèques
je vous dis des joueurs de clubs etc des
joueurs tout le temps quoi
si vous commencez l'échecs à 80 ans je
vais vous dire bon ben peut-être que
vous leur gamme Alzheimer mais comme
vous commencez les chèques tôt et que
tous les jours de votre vie
Alzheimer je pense que vous êtes quand
même
pas les premiers candidats mais
alors retour B4 a été joué donc toujours
un pion de plus pour pour aller raisin
ici et là c'est 5 avec le Pione 4 qui
qui va tomber et si tu prends là je
prends il y a ce plan qui va tomber
encore et aussi depuis on a trois qui
peut tomber un jour je pense qu'elle
Raisa elle est très bien parti ici et
c'est des raisins gagnent cette partie
là et ben le match sera quasiment plié
entre les deux joueurs parce que il
faudra absolument que à portoff fasse
deux sur deux
pour revenir au score
il y a eu un tour des 6 que l'on attend
on n'aime pas du tout donc là j'imagine
ça a été le 5
que se passe-t-il si je le mange
je pense
ok 6 prise tu comprends je pousse et si
tu prends pas je pousse mon pion mon
cadet
très très dur quand même pour
pour Abdou ici avec les noirs
et qui a déjà un pied dans la dans la
demi-finale
pour C6 cavalent on prépare encore une
fois le couteau B6
il y a trois G4 merci beaucoup tout ça
l'ouverture c'était trop dur pour moi
c'était il y a beaucoup de cases tu vois
il y avait cinq cases d'écart j'ai pas
vu
quand c'est pas loin ça va je vois par
contre on est à 5 cases ça devient un
petit peu long pour mes yeux et des fois
je râpe des trucs comme ça donc voilà ca
va les prendre n'était pas possible mais
on serait ce que je masque quand même
tomber 6 on va continuer à pousser des
pions et ici là je pense sont
complètement gagnants quoi
comment on continue H3 malheur bien
comme ça on va pouvoir avoir plus de
mobilité avec la tour qui pourra qui
pourrait maintenant
bouger genre ton là et foulard ou tour
là et foulards par exemple il y a plein
de possibilités
faire attention à pas mettre le foot
devant et ça fait le cavalier quand même
attention même tomber trois fois qu'elle
a pas mal aussi tourbouges tourbé 6 ça a
l'air très très dur quand même pour pour
les Noirs à même le Roland qui peut
remonter ici
pas trop comment il va réussir à sauver
cavalier
et foulard
il y a eu la prise ici et là attention
que j'ai envie de continuer à boucher ma
tour moi je mets pour un
bien et c'est simple
on devient
c'est ça ouais c'est ça
ok
très très jolie
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il fait un livret
avec les Blancs
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il fait moins bien
j'avoue
à la base François j'avais pas marqué
les amis pour ce stream là j'ai marqué
maître fiel ce que vous savez que je
suis encore maître fille en fait pour
l'instant je serai mis prochain congrès
donc dans quelques mois et en fait et
ben j'ai été j'ai été un petit peu
comment dire
prix de cours avec avec cheesecom fr qui
a publié le fait que j'allais c'est le
MI Stéphane Massac qui a les commenter
l'événement et du coup moi j'avais tout
préparé avec mes trois filles j'avais
dit bon je mettrai je mettrai le mettre
international quand j'aurai eu le titre
officiellement comme Emma ils m'ont sur
tous les réseaux sociaux ils ont marqué
émis partout et ben j'étais obligé de
sortir
le MI aujourd'hui donc du coup ça y est
mais officiellement c'est pas encore le
cas la fille n'a pas encore accepté mais
normalement il y a pas de raison qu'il
refuse
j'espère qu'on va refusé parce que là du
coup je vais pleurer je vous garantis
mais sinon ça devrait être bon
avec mes 18 normes
ok tour ici peut-être le plus vite de
manger
et pousser égaux quoi
contre le jeu
tomber si cela probablement
aussi pour échanger les pièces forcées
de faire appel
dans ses capables
alors ici j'ai quand même tour B7
peut-être c'est ça qui veut
tu prends là je prends la
je pense ça va être abandon très
prochainement pour à vous autora qui qui
joue pas bien ici là
22 secondes pour les Noirs entre 2000
pour pour aller raisin qui a une belle
position là
le pion qui va avancer très vite retour
là j'attends là
et si il bouge la Toraya qu'elle a
terminé
ça a l'air complètement fini tu vas pas
de coup pour
pour
[Musique]
les joueurs qui ont l'air d'être des
contraintes voilà qui relative donc
j'étais sûr que j'étais sûr que
[Musique]
vous savez qu'on a un petit on a un
petit décalage d'une minute en fait
et donc c'est pour ça que la partie est
terminée chez eux c'est terminé mais
chez nous c'est pas encore terminé
il a il a fait une grosse partie encore
firou il est présent dans cet endroit il
veut il veut gagner la partie il veut
gagner le match c'est clair et net on
prend ici
en pleine forme
j'ai quatre H4 c'est ça
tu as la fin
ok il s'est laissé mater et donc 2-0
pour
2-0 pour pour aller raisin fier aux gens
en ce match assez incroyable on va
revenir un petit peu avec
avec les autres parties on a Magnus qui
a gagné contre
gros tabataba aussi une baisse surprise
parce que la finale elle est franchement
pas l'air facile du tout pour ma tenue
il a réussi à
transformer ça tourbé 7 ah c'est
incroyable
pourquoi sur reprend il y a échec en
super ici mais ici dis-moi je m'en fous
de ce cavalier moi je joue ça et une
fois que tu le prends je prends donc
avec une valeur de partir et maintenant
j'ai un peu passer qui est hyper loin
donc j'ai un pion de moins mais tu as
des pions doublés donc c'est un peu
moins grave et sur E5 l'option qui
avance et qui avance et qui en fait
quasiment inarrêtable
et pendant que tu apprends le pur là-bas
bah moi je vais continuer et me créer
des capacités ici c'est hyper joli le
pire c'est qu'en plus ce thème là va
travailler avec un élève il y a pas très
longtemps le pion passé éloigné
et c'est un exemple monstrueux qui ont
passé
la fin de partie est incroyable cavalier
prend F6 la est trop belle ça je trouve
que c'est c'est monstrueux
c'est monstrueux ce qu'il a fait
sacrifier un pion pour avoir ce pion
basé qui va avancer avancer avancer et
pendant en fait que les blancs vont
chercher ce plan
et ben les Noirs vont se préparer pour
aller de l'autre côté pas de ce pion
Marius c'est très bien il va pas la dame
mais en revenant ici il attire le roi et
cavalier là-bas pendant que lui et ben
il passe ici avec ses pièces en fait je
veux pas être partout avec les Blancs
c'est incroyable
maintenant
on prend et maintenant moi je l'ai pu
passer sur les deux ailes et le temps
que le chercher c'est trop tard quoi
alors
Master Class franchement la finale alors
la partie en elle-même c'était une
partie un peu bizarre Magnus mais la
finale juste beaucoup trop jolie quoi ok
donc pour l'instant les scores on a
Magnus qui mène un et demi à 0 et demi
contre Tabata Bay on a Ali resa firosa
qui mène 2-0 face à abusotov on a so
ouest qui mène 2-0 aussi face à elianov
et carwana lazavik a eu deux matchs nuls
aussi donc pour l'instant on a deux
joueurs qui sont qui sont quasiment sur
un de
se qualifier
en demi-finale on a furosa et Elena il y
a encore deux parties mais en tout cas
c'est bien parti pour alors je vous
laisse avec une petite page de pub et on
se revoit d'ici 5 10 minutes
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà je suis de retour pour cette
troisième partie des quarts de finale de
Champions
édition et nous avons
Maxime avec les Blancs contre tabac
abeilles avec les Noirs donc le score
c'est de 1 et demi à 0 et demi je vais
vous le mettre là
je vais vous l'afficher le score pour
que vous puissiez le voir
et donc un et demi pour Magnus
contre 0 et demi pour tabac tabeuil
alors
il y a quatre parties en tout je vous
rappelle quatre parties de 15 + 3
si Magnus gagne cette partie là
Magnus aura du coup deux et demi sur
trois ce qui veut dire que tabac
d'abonner ne pourra pas revenir au score
donc en cas de victoire de Magnus ben il
jouera pas la quatrième partie ça me
paraît assez normal et logique comme
système
à domicile
et donc ça c'est une Espagnole assez
classique
et
donc ici souvent sur Full G5 les noirs
ont des possibilités pour un jeu H6 G5
et attaquer sur le roi blanc le problème
c'est que manus n'a pas encore roquet
donc c'est pas évident de vouloir
commencer à pousser les pions là-bas
donc là généralement on recule le fou
que va dessiner Magnus dans cette partie
vous savez que les partants qui sont
décalés là on a la partie de Magnus
contre la ganov Caravana lazavik et on
aura aussi besoin qui vont commencer
dans décaler il y a toujours un petit
peu de temps entre les parties pour
l'instant la seule qui a commencé c'est
celle-là
et en plus une partie un peu critique
parce que c'est Magnus gagne partie et
ben
ce sera
ce sera terminé pour ce match on a aussi
et c'est Rosa qui Abdou qui aimait 2-0
pour l'instant et
alienov qui est mené aussi 2-0 par saw
Wesley donc c'est deux parties de match
terminé aussi rapidement et bien sûr par
contre dans le match de l'azalik contre
Cauna là c'est sûr qu'on va aller au
bout du bout parce qu'ils ont deux ma
tenue pour l'instant donc même s'il y a
une victoire d'un joueur et ben il y
aura un quatrième partie si ce jour là
donc c'est sûr et sur un certain qu'on
se verra encore pendant deux matchs de
partie
donc là il y a eu le G5 fougères et dame
7 qui est assez classique souvent le fou
qui va enlever ça tourne aussi et là en
fait c'est un peu compliqué la position
parce qu'en fait on se rend compte que
tabattabeille il a quand même poussé les
deux ailes vous voyez donc son rang
c'est pas trop où est-ce qu'on va le
mettre
donc c'est la seule petite chose un peu
bizarre peut-être de la part de
la cage j'ai 5 très souvent le pion bah
il est encore B7 on entend comme ça et
on garde l'option d'un jour de faire un
rock
audition n'a pas d'option de rock
donc le roi noir va sûrement rester au
centre ou des fois on peut aussi ok mais
du coup un peu moins pousser les pieds
on va voir un peu comment ça va se
passer dans tous les cas le roi noir il
est assez ouvert donc c'est pas c'est
pas évident comme pose
la partie c'est une
position assez classique
une sorte de catalane qu'on a pu voir
déjà tout à l'heure
et dès que j'ai les positions des autres
je vous dirai pour l'instant c'est pas
très excitant
voir ce qui se passe à côté
un message en tout cas important je
crois
ok ça je l'avais déjà vu c'est bon c'est
par rapport à l'événement en fait par
rapport à l'événement c'est comme des
fois on a des messages internes
ok donc prise F prend
et maintenant ben écoute petit rock va
être chaud moi j'aime beaucoup la
position de Magnus j'aime énormément la
production je pense que vous en pensez
dans le chat de cette position je trouve
que les Blancs se sentent pas mal du
tout parce que la colonne F qui va avoir
qui va apparaître pour pour la Tour
Blanche et le roi noir qui a pas d'abris
donc les noirs qui c'est pas toi comment
ils vont jouer oui il fait ils font un
petit rock quand même
mécan tout ça ça fait descend
donc petit rock sûrement et après avoir
comment les blancs ils poursuivent
l'attaque c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore si clair mais
je trouve que la potion blanche c'est
quand même beaucoup plus facile à jouer
beaucoup plus compact et il y a trop de
problèmes chez les noirs sur le long
terme ça risque d'être difficile pour
ta bataille
c'est une position qui est extrêmement
facile à jouer pour les blancs avec en
plus un petit avantage et du coup je
pense que c'est compliqué quand même
salut François jacquard
salut à toi
bienvenue alors je vois que slow
ça va commencer il y a pas encore la
partie c'est pas lancé
et à fille roux n'a pas commencé non
plus
on dirait qu'il a lu le cours d'anus
l'italienne
et toi huit donc là j'imagine
qu'il a envie de bouger la dame en fait
pour garder la colonne il faut rester
comme ça mais attention il y a tout
compris
fou qui va être
qui va être possible pour
une menace en tout cas pour enfin des
Noirs donc dame C2 ça garde le fou et ça
se passait la tour mais la dame en CD
c'est pas forcément la meilleure casse
qu'elle est peut-être fou prend aussi
c'est possible pour se décaler après que
tu as plutôt en E2
mais je sais pas trop si ça va aider
les blancs de mangeant aussi ou pas
parce qu'elle a un bon petit crâne ça va
t'abais
et
[Musique]
faut croire ici c'est franc ici il y a
quatre parties en tout cas parties c'est
une bague
donc quatre parties pour l'instant et
puis
et puis enfin trois ou quatre parties il
y en a quatre dans le pire des cas et il
y aura trois en fait trois parties si
jamais il y a un joueur qui arrive à
deux et demi avant donc par exemple on a
pour l'instant le score de 1 et demi à 0
et demi pour Magnus et si Magnus gagne
cette partie et ben il aura du coup deux
et demi sur trois et deux buts sur 3 et
ben ça gagne le match parce que la
quatrième partie apportée pour du beurre
donc sera archi gagnant pour
pour ma news qui fait cavalier H4 c'est
quoi ce cavalier H4 sur pion H4 et moi
j'ai froid regardez bien comment c'est
joli prise et le cavalier F6 est perdu
monstrueux oui il y a plein de thèmes
qui arrivent par rapport à la position
et maintenant ça doit trouver la superbe
idée de cavalier H4 pour aller en F5
pour taquiner la dame le pion H6 le roi
en 11 et 8 et après cavalier H4 je pense
franchement les amis que cette partie va
être
assez courte franchement Magnus là
mais on se sentait hein depuis le début
je vous avais dit que c'était bizarre
d'avoir joué B5 et G5 les deux vont pas
ensemble généralement ces positions et
après cavalier H4 cavaliers F5 la
position est déjà extrêmement difficile
on peut imaginer par exemple comme
cavalier F5
tours F5 avec Dame F3 il y a plein de
problèmes sur le cavalier sur le pur F7
de partout j'ai la paire de fou aussi je
vous rappelle et j'ai aussi des coups
plus tard même pour H4 attaquer un petit
peu le roi noir cette position est
extrêmement extrêmement pénible à
défendre pour pour les noirs et
franchement
là où est Magnus il est l'heure sur la
caméra elle est tellement serein
tellement tranquille
et je vais vous dire cette partie elle
va couper court je pense
parce que déjà que la position en
elle-même moi je trouve qu'elle est très
mauvaise pour les pour les Noirs mais en
plus d'être mauvaise et ben tu as
l'impression que vraiment en fait
elle est difficile quoi et chaque coup
noir va être un coup précis à trouver un
coup qui pourra limite être perdant
directement si tu fermes avec ou quoi on
va être les coudes noires valent
tellement cher par rapport au goût des
blancs parce qu'il voyait des blancs ils
peuvent faire tout ce qu'ils veulent
même si prochain coup je fais H3 et ben
c'est un coup qui me permet d'améliorer
la position et continuer l'attaque toi
tu as un problème c'est que tu as joué
tout ça et tu as affaibli et tu peux pas
revenir en arrière malheureusement là je
suis sûr que les Noirs s'il le pouvaient
y frégisent quoi il reculer
pas été mis avant et Caval et H4 c'est
un coup extrêmement joli alors il y a eu
fougère
et maintenant question importante alors
fujica tu as découvre aussi le voyez la
diagonale et depuis un F7 donc non à
voir parce que par exemple il y a des
idées bon ça marchera pas pour l'instant
ça pourrait être une idée un jour même
cavalier 6 qui est une possibilité vous
voyez il y a un clouage ici tac le
cavalier ici il y a plein de
possibilités mais bien sûr vu l'attaque
qu'on a on a généralement pas envie de
vouloir changer les dames généralement
on va changer les dames que quand
on a des matériels d'avance ou un truc
comme ça dans cette position là on va
tellement un avantage dans l'attaque on
n'a pas du tout envie d'échanger des
pièces donc si je fais un coup de fil
Dame des deux pour venir en F2 moi
j'aime bien un des deux
je me demande ce que vont faire les
Noirs parce qu'après ça tu prends là le
problème c'est le même
à moins que cavalle prend un 4 ça qui va
faire
je pense à ça encore une fois j'ai rien
calculé et ouais qui avaler prendre un
cadre ça a l'air pas mal parce que si je
prends là tu prends la
c'est chaud
mais si je prends là et tu prends là je
peux manger là je peux manger là mais
j'ai aussi Dame des cinq en fait c'est
extrêmement compliqué comme position
vous voyez que ça peut partir dans tous
les sens très très vite mais
qui avait des F5 aussi une possibilité
mais qu'avec ça que ça va changer les
pièces
après faut prendre bien ca va aller
prendre cavaler prend et tu reprends là
ben oui ben j'ai la barre de fou etc
mais j'ai l'impression que
ça pourrait être pire quand même pour
les noirs et ma vue c'est d'être le
meilleur coup ça s'enlève de cavaliers
prend un 4 ça menace d'un meuf 2 voyez
venir là comme ça
ou ce chemin là c'est le même au final
mais ça empêche qu'elle va les prendre
le 4 donc c'est vraiment un très bon
choix de la part de Magnus devoir mettre
Damien qui va faire dame F2 imparable et
cavalier F5 toujours dans l'air qu'elle
va les F5 qui avait déjà 6 ça me H3
c'est une possibilité et la F2 aussi
c'est une grosse possibilité d'ailleurs
je pense que la position est beaucoup
trop dure pour les noirs
alors ensuite peut-être qu'il peut la
défendre mais ça m'a l'air difficile
maintenant qu'on y pense
parce que si tu veux rester sur la
diagonale ici il faut te mettre en a
deux mais en a à deux tu es pas descendu
et il peut se passer des choses plus
tard donc fouder avec les jouets et il
se dit moi je m'en fous mais l'avantage
de fodéens c'est que maintenant si les
noirs
donc je sais pas quel moment je sais pas
si maintenant ou si après que je
pourrais faire ça intermédiaire par
exemple il y a pas un coup de dame
manger ici moi j'aime bien ça
en l'air c'est une horreur tout
simplement tu peux aussi manger en D1 et
dire bon
cavalière parce que de fou et ben il est
plus là
donc les noirs on parle droit d'échanger
les pièces voyez
[Musique]
en termes on va dire juste
positionnellement parlant les noirs on
parle droit échanger de fou parce que la
case F5 est tellement importante dans la
position que t'as pas le droit vraiment
d'échanger les pièces tu dois reculer le
fou là ou là tu es obligé je peux pas
laisser un cavaliers arrivent en F1
comme ça c'est vraiment
trop difficile donc là moi je mets un
petit fou aussi mais même après un coup
comme ça j'ai quand même cavalier F5
peut-être possible
et
H4 tu as l'impression de prendre la
position elle est elle est impossible à
tenir pour les pour les Noirs c'est
c'est beaucoup beaucoup trop difficile
en fait beaucoup trop difficile et ça a
l'air complètement perdu
et à ce niveau là en plus avec Magnus
aux commandes des blancs dans une
position assez bonne vous imaginez
vraiment le désastre que ça peut
occasionner si c'était alors comme moi
qui avait les lobes je peux toujours
donner une pièce un couple comme j'ai
l'habitude de faire par contre Magnus
c'est pas son genre de rater des
positions gagnantes et quand il a un
avantage comme celui-ci je le vois pas
du tout le raté et ne pas gagner la
partie ah il a mangé des
F5 est extrêmement fort alors je sais
pas si
cavalier F5 prend bien ou aussi
d'apprendre un puis
il y a eu il y a eu cavalier F5 dame 6
maintenant et la pollution si vous
comparez les rois
comparer les cavaliers comparer le
cavalier au bord le fou enfin juste
comparer les caisses et vous rendez
compte que chaque pièce noire est
extrêmement mal en fait on peut pas
comparer les pièces juste pas trop de
problèmes
donc demain c'est un petit coup malin
qui permet de clouer et ben c'est les
quatre
on a aussi H4 que j'aime bien
et puis après les tactiques font vont en
vont arriver ça a l'air beaucoup trop
dur pour pour les Noirs Magnus qui nous
fait pour l'instant une masterclass sur
cette partie alors on va on va voir si
la meuf 3 c'est aussi très bien c'est
une bague ça aussi une grande une grande
possibilité
par exemple de menacer pour manger F6
voilà il a joué H4 mais bon ici tous les
coups sont bons même si on voit que tu
as le jauge redescends il remonte à
chaque fois en pratique pour les Noirs
c'est juste impossible de tenir alors on
va l'avoir rapidement quand même notre
petit frenchy donc on a ici
qu'elle est blanc contre les raisins
ferroja qui mène 2-0 le français
allez raisin qui mène 2-0 face
à Abdou Abdou qui a été vainqueur
derrière de l'émission il y a quelques
éditions c'était il y a il a gagné je
crois la deuxième édition ou la
troisième je sais plus Jean-Pierre doute
Abdou
et
Cavalia 5 x 5 places les trucs j'imagine
que je ne connais pas moi-même et
firou qui qui réfléchit qui a 9 minutes
qu'on trouve quand je mette les caméras
quand même
et Filou qui réfléchit contre Abdou ici
je peux vous mettre le score aussi si
vous voulez tout ce qui est quand même
très gentil vous savez
et avec le score vous allez voir que
vous allez
avoir un peu plus clair
qui se passe ici donc 2-0 pour l'instant
pour fuir aux gens et
donc il faut une nulle il y a encore
deux parties à faire
une nulle pour
pour firou et il sera qualifié pour les
demi-finales de ce tournoi donc il a
encore de partir celle là et une
prochaine si personne là il a encore une
chance de faire nul à la prochaine
et
par contre s'il arrive à faire match nul
maintenant ou gagner et ben le match
s'arrête net il y aura pas de crème
pâtisserie
au score
donc ici un paire de Fougan pour les
blancs pardofu c'est pas négligeable par
défaut et majorité au centre
un jour je pourrais plus tard pousser
mon centre donc quand même une position
qui est pas mal pour
pour le genre
ouzbek avec les Blancs j'ai l'impression
que il y a pas mal réussi son ouverture
en tout cas Abdou mais bon vous
inquiétez pas que ferosa est là et fier
aux hommes a pas laisser passer sa
chance de se qualifier
sont fait rapidement un petit tour chez
So Wesley
contre
nul il a pour l'instant deux victoires
alors à zéro
et donc ceux qui va vouloir gagner enfin
pas perdre avec les Blancs il y a une
belle position et
5 c'est une casserole ici il a les
blancs je pense pas que saut va perdre
ce match et rapidement dans le match de
carvana
ici
il y a une tenue pour l'instant donc là
sont complètement égalité il y aura une
quatrième partie de sur dans ce match là
parce qu'avec avec un un
pour ce quasi il faut deux et demi et
du coup ils vont devoir aller au bout de
ce match donc un peu plus ici il y a
qu'à aller prendre mes trois et ton
prends à 5 et tu as l'impression quand
même que la position est assez égale
j'aime bien les Noirs quand même
parce que rien n'est prendre des quatre
aussi possible
quel est le mieux je ne sais pas mais
l'idée c'est qu'après le petit pion à 4
bloque quand même les pions A3 et B2
peut-être que les noirs sont un peu
mieux parce que sont plus d'espace et un
pion de plus de ce côté là peut-être que
voilà pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait nuit
chez la David alors je passe la lumière
ou pas dans tous les cas même par la
fenêtre on voit qu'il fait un petit peu
tard donc il habite enfin en tout cas je
sais pas où il habite mais il vient de
là
Bosnie je crois
que c'est la Bosnie son pays
sans doute et du coup il est plus à
l'est donc il doit avoir peut-être
au moins deux trois heures de décalage
je pense par rapport à nous
donc voilà c'est pas
alors biélorus ah pardon je suis désolé
pourtant je suis assez bon généralement
sur les noms sur les pays des joueurs
alors moi j'aimerais bien revenir sur 45
quand même je suis intéressé par cette
partie et par contre le résultat qui est
qui est pas mis qui est mal mis on va
changer un peu tout ça
et
[Musique]
Magnus qui est en balle de match il y a
cette partie le match sera gagné pour
lui alors je vais venir un petit peu en
allant voir ce qui s'est passé ah j'aime
beaucoup cette partie parce que je
trouve que cavalier H4 est trop jolie
c'est pour ça que j'ai vraiment envie de
passer du temps sur cette partie là
tac H4 ton G8 prise tu reprends et
pourquoi il me dit cache pas que c'est
pas bon ce qu'il dit apparemment
cavalier B3 je me tourner
était une possibilité bon qui est ça
reste difficile à comprendre moi je vais
manger ici ton roi il a quoi là
c'est pas humain ok toi j'ai eu alors
logique faut H4 et B4 d'un F3 ouais les
blancs sont parfaits contrôle dans la
position et cavaler qui joue pas bien
les pièces sont toutes horribles il y a
7 minutes entre 5
Magnus ici il a un très très bel
avantage pour tabac Tabe et en plus il
rigole
je sais pas je sais pas ce qu'il fait
rire mais en tout cas en tout cas ça
amuse beaucoup cette position
et
[Musique]
pas trop il joue si c'est ici Bacro
Bacro il joue et il joue la la division
3 non j'ai regardé un petit peu pendant
la pause on peut accro à éliminer le
genre allemand enfin le genre allemand
l'ancien joueur allemand qui maintenant
et
uruguayen Georges Meyer et là il jouait
contre vous
j'ai pas eu tout vu les parties
malheureusement et freiner Laurent
Freyssinet qui joue la division 2 et
d'un à éliminer drief 2 et demi
à 0 et demi donc ce qualifie du coup
donc
la vitamine OK
l'enjeu c'est quoi bah c'est un gros
tournoi avec pas mal de prix donc là
c'est financier sûrement enfin surtout
et en fait c'est un tournoi si tu veux
qui
qui est ce jour en six étapes donc tu as
6 tournois comme ça dans chaque tournoi
du cumul des points et à la fin les
pointes font gagner des prix en général
donc par dorton là le vainqueur de la
Division 1 prend 30 000 dollars il va
falloir qu'il dure quatre jours cinq
jours et dans chaque toit tu as les prix
aussi et je crois qu'à la fin tu as un
trophée en plus avec encore de l'argent
bref ils se mettent bien les joueurs qui
font les divisions 1 et 2 et
dans tous les cas c'est un truc sympa
et là ça va être très très dur pour
tabathalie
qui
se pose des questions là qu'est-ce que
je vais faire c'est dur car c'est en
face c'est pas
facile d'ailleurs
la partie où au Magnus a fait n'importe
quoi dans l'ouverture mais t'as pas
réussi à le battre il a même perdu la
partie de ta bataille donc ça montre à
quel point un Magnus est fort en
ressource même quand il est foutu et ben
il y a des ressources
hier d'apprendre aussi il veut jouer
qu'avait les F4 c'est ça
priori je crois que c'est ce qu'il veut
faire
et si tu veux dans boule bah je fais des
seins
Magnus qui va gagner et qui est là sans
lui un petit peu d'ailleurs
il faisait moins de malins la partie
d'avant
Magnus il faisait beaucoup moins de
malin mais là maintenant qui mène un et
demi sur deux complètement gagnants et
ben
il est un petit peu décontracté par
rapport à tout à l'heure
cavaliers 4 fourchette c'est un arabe
qui choisit qui participe par de base tu
avais des qualifications avec des avec
des participations avec un tournoi
online ça faisait un tournoi avec des
joueurs qui se qualifie d'office
enfin avec des gens qui qualifiés pardon
et tu avais aussi des joueurs qui
étaient invités parce qu'ils sont très
forts et au final enfin ça fait des
joueurs
tu as tout le plateau tu as un Magnus
Tasso ta fille roux tu as vraiment tous
les meilleurs joueurs du monde et tu as
quelques joueurs qui sont un peu moins
fort quand même comme tabattable comme
la David comme elianov qui peuvent se
qualifier et du coup participer contre
ce genre là donc ça reste quand même
très intéressant
de pouvoir participer vous voyez que ça
va t'abaisse un très très danger
scène il est quand même très content
c'est pas tous les jours où il peut le
jouer donc ça reste quand même je pense
une belle expérience pour lui
donc Dame des trois
la position qui est qui est très
vivifiant pour
très difficile pour
pour
tous les pions
donc
je crois d'ailleurs après c'est
tellement les mêmes les mêmes positions
c'est une Espagnole
c'était une espagnole
il a il a raison c'est une bague
là on va avoir
la fin qui va être je pense imminente
tout rêve 3
et je ne sais pas comment ça va sans
remettre cette partie je pense que
l'avait fait est imparable Magnus qui
est en face va pas craquer ça c'est
impossible parce qu'on dirait pas avoir
du coup un petit filou pendant ce temps
là parce que cette partie on peut dire
qu'elle a gagné maintenant je pense qu'à
ce niveau là pas trop de surprise
imaginez fou là est hors-la et puis ça
va être abandon donc je pense qu'on va
aller voir ailleurs
que nous fait Ali raisin avec les Blancs
un peu difficile pour le noir avec ce
petit pion isolé mais si je suis actif
avec les Noirs ça peut le faire donc là
c'est
au noir de jeu en cavalier 7 je défends
le pion dessin
et
comment je continue derrière c'est pas
évident
d'être à cette tour DS7 pour essayer de
m'activer chasser le cavalier
il peut être intéressant
mais je suis pas fan du tout de la
position
de à les raisins parce que je trouve
qu'elle a pas mal de tension je fous que
tape là-bas
isolé vous voyez le 2 est gratuit alors
rien n'est vraiment gratuit tu le sais
je prends des 5 déjà commencé et puis en
plus il y a toujours vachement doucement
des colonnes donc là par exemple après
cavalier 7 pour
enlever ce pion de la prise du four et
pour augmenter la pression sur la
colonne D donc sur une prise en 4 au
pire des cas des cavaliers 34 mais au
meilleur des cas j'ai mieux peut-être
cavalier F5 par exemple qui peut
attaquer là-haut est attaquer ici il y a
un peu tout en prise en fait
[Musique]
ce qui compte juste
faire tourner vite
sur cavalier 7 et c'est de récupérer en
force pion de 5 ça apparaît qui pourrait
être pas mal mais il faut réussir à le
faire c'est pas évident
pas évident du tout c'est un fou de
retraité jouet
ben je pense que firou serait content
c'est clairement son son plan ici de pas
perdre ainsi il perd pas cette partie il
est qualifier pour la demi-finale
donc là il mène 2-0 dans ce match
d'ailleurs le score est pas bon vous
savez que le score à chaque fois il
faudra résister
le score n'est pas bon ici
maintenant le score est bon donc du coup
un match nul
sur les deux parties qui restent vont
lui offrir
le sésame ticket pour pour la
demi-finale
et donc bien sûr il joue pour la nuit
bien sûr il peut gagner ça change pas
mais clairement ici quand il joue pour
la nul et il joue pour la qualification
c'est l'enjeu numéro 1 carrément c'est
parti
c'est quand même pas facile hein pas mal
de pression dans la position moi je suis
chef iru même si vous voyez que la jauge
elle est quand même au milieu etc il y a
moins de temps la pendule pour Firo et
une position toujours un peu tendue pas
mal de tactiques dans l'air pas mal de
thèmes
donc je vous avoue que j'ai un peu peur
quand même pour pour aller Raisa ici je
trouve que c'est pas évident
pas du tout
si je précise quelques couches je pense
qu'il va réussir à gagner mais
s'il est imprécis ça va être difficile
et il faut faire attention
même dommage 3 et pas débile
un peu les pièces sur le roi blanc quoi
ça s'ouvre la position il prend 4
maintenant alors tout à l'heure ça
marche pas trop de manger 4 on avait dit
parce qu'il y avait un problème avec le
vis-à-vis et avec avaler F5 qui attaqué
là il y avait tout qui était en prise et
aussi puis on le sait d'accord
maintenant qu'il est à jeu fous des 4
et ben j'ai plus qu'à valait F5 parce
que j'ai plus la reprise vous voyez donc
c'est
intéressant quoi
et maintenant il faut il faut que je
bouge la dame du moins que la défendre
c'est à ça en l'air il y a aussi un
petit
avec ma tour là il y a un vis-à-vis qui
s'est mis en place avec une découverte
possible donc il y a aussi il y a aussi
fou B7 qui est intéressant
mettre une batterie ici ça pourrait être
vraiment très très bien mais
premièrement il faut il faut déjà
commencer par par voir ce qui se passe
avec ce vis-à-vis et ça parlant c'est
pas possible
ou pas non je crois que ça marche pas
j'essaie de faire un truc comme ça mais
je crois que ça marche jamais pour
cavalier
ce matin parable là c'est moi qui suis
matte
donc je peux pas faire les trucs jolis
comme ça malheureusement tu dois trouver
une solution et il y a eu tour des 8
dans F3
ok donc il y a toujours ce vis-à-vis
de possible parce que ça c'est un coup
ou pas
ça m'a l'air sympa de la part de
firou parce que maintenant sur cavalier
FC
candeur qui n'importe quoi
et maintenant oui tu pourras plus faire
le même thème donc grâce à la C6 et ben
je garde ce thème là et j'ai fou aussi
qui arrive donc c'est assez intéressant
j'ai trouvé 7 je regarde un petit peu
tout ça mais torcer maintenant
Tom G6 hop dame qui vient un petit peu
se défendre là j'ai encore coupé cette
et je vais encore les pressions sur le
fout des quatre etc je pense que firmou
Sangare il est mal au temps par contre
il est très mal au temps mais sa
position a l'air de d'être pas mal je
pense qu'il a survécu
le Québec j'ai jamais visité encore mais
un jour peut-être
ce serait sympa
parce que moi je voyage beaucoup
c'est pas pareil c'est pas la même chose
mais j'avoue que partir un Québec ça
pourrait être
une belle aventure aussi c'est un
tournoi un jour là-bas ou quoi ça
pourrait être sympa
on verra c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore pour aujourd'hui en tout cas
mais si jamais un jour il y a un truc
pourquoi pas partir dans
dans ces pays là pour être cool
et fille roux avec mal au temple on sait
comment il joue en Bullet on sait tout
ça donc
[Musique]
pas trop de soucis là-dessus pour pour
fier
je sais que c'est pas top ici pas comme
en France
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'en France on a un pays
maintenant qui commence à calme pas mal
du tout aux échecs
après chaque pays est intéressant qui
est important de chacun moi j'ai fini
plein de pays
dans beaucoup de pays d'Europe
et c'est toujours cool de jouer contre
d'autres gens qu'on ne connaît pas dans
d'autres pays et
essayer de profiter un petit peu tout ça
donc
là il faut partir avec la dame
en Espagne surtout ben j'habite en
Espagne donc j'ai pas mal journée
j'ai joué dans ma vie donc j'en ai
Thalie en Espagne je vais au Portugal
j'ai joué en Belgique une fois pas plus
une seule fois j'ai joué
au Pays-Bas
j'ai joué
en Inde
sur plein de pays j'ai joué chez Jean
Roumanie j'ai joué en Serbie
j'ai joué
[Musique]
non c'est moi c'est moi
je suis à Cannes bah j'ai plusieurs
clubs en fait tu peux être c'est pas
comme au foot tu peux être dans
plusieurs clubs dans plusieurs pays
différents j'ai un club en Espagne et
j'ai un club en France et j'ai aussi un
club
en Belgique
c'est trois clubs
vous imaginez un peu la chance qu'ils
ont raison
pour pour trois pays pour l'instant
et peut-être plus simple
si vous faites payer d'un pays
francophone je serais content de jeux
pour vous
alors tout revient alors que se
passait-il sur dame prend ah ok donc on
est quatre il y avait cavaliers F6 pour
aller manger la tour en A8 je pense hein
c'est c'est l'idée ici
d'un F5 prise cavalier prend on va
récupérer le pion dedans firou qui a
plus de temps à la pendule 40 secondes
mais il va récupérer le pur B2 qui est
forcée parce que vous décrète pas
possible
et tout a l'air de de bien se passer
pour pour Furon qui va obtenir sûrement
l'égalité après ton premier de
ben en fait
sont pas en même temps tu as chaque pays
qui ont leur Dar club c'est un peu
différent je sais que la Belgique et la
France des fois ça se marchait un peu
dessus mais par exemple en France on
joue à Tark club c'était deux matchs par
week-end là où je jouais alors qu'en
Belgique c'est un match par week-end et
c'est pas les mêmes weekends tout le
temps donc il y a beaucoup de bouquins
qui étaient pas ensemble mais de temps
en temps il y avait un match en même
temps mais c'est assez rare
et maintenant en plus que je suis comme
mon club s'est qualifié pour le Top 16
et ben maintenant je joue que une
semaine par an et c'est en
avril ou en mai je crois donc du coup ça
va quoi a priori par rapport à la Ligue
Belge je suis pas trop pénalisé et aussi
par rapport à Ligue espagnole il y aura
peut-être des matchs aussi en parallèle
mais il faudra voir mais espagnol
commence en janvier
en fait toutes les différences en fait
en fait nous en Espagne je joue en de
janvier avril je crois ou en deux envies
à avril par contre c'est tous les
week-end tous les dimanches je crois
tous les dimanches il y a un match
pendant trois mois
donc
[Musique]
janvier à ça et en Belgique en fait des
matchs à ce moment là j'en sais rien on
verra mais après bon ben pas toujours
c'est tout
pas toujours club de ment non pas moi et
canoë en si bien qualifié c'était
vraiment sympa cette année hein on a eu
en plus des gros gros match contre
notamment à jeun et Aix-en-Provence
c'était vraiment
OK
donc tomber de et ici maintenant mais il
y a un problème sur le pion à deux et on
voit Abdou qui commence à prendre pas
mal de temps et là on voit les joueurs
qui ont terminé mais par contre on va
pas bien
qui s'est passé
les gens
que ce qu'ils passés
en fait bon on a on a vraiment un
[Musique]
du retard par rapport à
ce qui se passe eux c'est beaucoup pour
jetons
et finalement
je crois qu'à
tomber un
truc bizarre
comment il a gagné
je peux pas défendre les deux pièces
pour D1 cavalier F3 il faut prendre et
c'est abondant ok bah écoutez Abdou qui
a bien craqué en ce match à bout qui
était pas en forme franchement et on a
une belle calife du coup de Alisa qui va
gagner 3-0 ce match avec Carlsen qui est
aussi venu à gagner sa partie donc 45
qui qualifie pour les de mes finales
contre je rentrais je vais vous montrer
après la après je montrerai le petit
graphique pour voir un peu contre qui va
jouer donc 45 qualités pour une
demi-finale Abdou qualifié aussi pour
finale so Wesley qui est qualifié aussi
pour la demi-finale avec 3-0 et le
dernier match d'ailleurs une belle
surprise ici de lasavik contre carwana
qui a un savoir qui et du coup là David
qui prend une option pour la dernière
partie en cas de en cas de match nul
dans cette partie qui se qualifiera pour
les demi-finales alors si je vous montre
un petit peu le
le bracket
bon à 45 qui qualifie déjà et qui jouera
contre le gagnant de lasalik kerwana on
a Sophie rouge qui sont déjà qualifiés
ensemble et en bas dans le tableau des
perdants et bon là qui joue contre le
perdant de la David carwana et en
dessous
c'est 4 qui seront en bas seront bien
sûr éliminés cette fois ci et après vous
savez qu'on peut sur requalifier en
remontant à la surface en gagnant les
losers Quatar finals Lunar Smith etc et
jusqu'à la finale jusqu'à la fin comme
l'avait fait d'ailleurs Magnus car cette
contre Nakamura il y a quelques tournois
donc on fait une petite pause de 5 10
minutes et on va se retrouver pour la
dernière partie de ce de cette journée
entre karwana avec les Blancs contre
lasavik dans un match qui va promettre
vraiment beaucoup d'actions par Cabana
avec les Blancs on va être obligé de
gagner cette partie pour arriver au
tie-breaks donc je vous dis à tout de
suite sur une petite pub et restez parmi
nous on revient dans quelques instants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur les chiquitiers
vous pouvez choisir parmi une multitude
de notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs ils émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales
restent sur l'échiquier jusqu'à ce
qu'elles soient effacées pour se faire
il suffit de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'emoji ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour pour cette dernière
partie des
excusez-moi le score je l'ai mal aimé il
y a deux un pardon pour pour la David
contre Caruana
pour revenir au score lors de ce petit
match donc pour l'instant il y a eu deux
nuls dans la deuxième partie puis une
victoire de Denis lazanic dans ce
minimal karwana allez blanc c'est la
partie et tu es obligé de gagner pour
forcer un départage
alors est-ce que vous savez comment se
passe les départages dans ce cas de
figure dans ce tournoi dans ces dans cet
événement comment se passe à votre avis
les départages est-ce que vous savez que
vous en souvenir que je sais qu'il y a
certains qui qui ont déjà
suivi cet événement pas mal de fois
est-ce que vous vous souvenez commençons
le départage moi je m'en souviens moi je
les connais moi je vous demande pour
vous
enchères c'est ça sympa de voir des
enchères bah c'est ça en plus tu as
raison Maigret
c'est exactement ça retire une seule
partie en cas d'égalité donc si jamais
car wanna gagne cette partie et ben il
va arriver au départage donc il y aura
deux deux il y aura une dernière partie
armagon oui mais les temps seront
seront utilisés un peu comme enchères
c'est-à-dire en fait que au lieu de
commencer un vrai magazon c'est quatre
contre cinq ou cinq contre six ça dépend
en minutes mais ici en fait c'est un
enchère c'est à dire qu'il y aura un
joueur qui aura 15 minutes et l'autre
genre qui aura gagné l'enchère par
exemple les deux joueurs ils vont donner
un temps avec lequel ils veulent bien
avoir les Noirs par exemple moi je dis
allez je marque 10 minutes par exemple
et et à mon adversaire va marquer par
exemple 8,50 et ben le joueur qui a mis
le plus petit temps va gagner la
recherche
et donc va prendre les noirs et 8
minutes 50 contre 15 donc dans ce cas là
il y a pas de rajout de temps c'est en
cas où
et
vous savez que les Noirs en cas de
réalité en cas de match leule et bien il
gagne l'armée donc les Noirs
gagnants la partie en cas de match nul
donc c'est un avantage d'avoir les Noirs
mais
tu as moins de temps
que les Blancs etc donc ça reste
difficile et en plus c'est du chaos donc
voilà c'est la moyenne de pouvoir
départager un peu tout ça et donc l'idée
c'est vraiment parier sur le fait
d'avoir les Noirs donc des fois c'est
important pour les gens dans le noir des
fois il préfère avoir les blancs et donc
du coup pourquoi bien de temps tu es
prêt à avoir les Noirs c'est un petit
peu ça le l'enjeu et donc ça c'est
intéressant comme comme des partages
c'est que jamais vu avant
et donc ce
démontage aura lieu si seulement si
carwana parvient à gagner cette partie
avec les Blancs
alors lui c'est pas une star wars Beck
il est biais de russe la famille Denis
lazalik alors pour faire un petit peu
son
CV niveau échec je pense qu'il est pas
très connu par vous parce que c'est pas
un joueur qui fait partie de lever de
mondial c'est un grand maître ça c'est
clair et en fait moi je l'ai connu si
vous voulez sur CSCOM parce que je
contre lui à de nombreuses reprises sur
les tournois comme l'état de Tuesday ou
sur les Arena Kings et c'est un genre
qui a plus de 3000 lots plus de 3000 et
en blitz c'est vraiment un monstre et du
coup bon j'ai été son cobaye pendant
plusieurs parties
et donc moi je vais repérer enfin je
l'ai connu comme ça
ensuite il a participé
aux Championnat du Monde de partir
rapide et de Blitz
et donc là moi j'étais intéressant de le
voir pour voir vraiment
où jusqu'où il va pouvoir aller parce
que il était hyper impressionnant sur
internet mais après en vrai sur un peu
différent et ben écoutez il a fait un
tournoi monstrueux il a été hyper
impressionnant que ce soit en blitz et
en rapide il a été extrêmement
impressionnant dans la de tournoi et
donc du coup il a un élo-feed à peu près
2500 presque 2600 je crois pas loin de
2600 mais encore un peu moins il me
semble vous pouvez vérifier pour ceux
qui sont sur le stream si vous voulez
vérifier et l'eau feed de la David pour
moi il a pas 2006 je dirais 25 60 70 je
dirais comme ça mais je suis pas sûr
et par contre en blitz c'est rapide je
pense qu'il a un vélo bien au dessus
et c'est un jeune qui qui est très bon
rapide qui va très vite et qui est très
dangereux donc voilà donc là il y a
marqué 207 50 ici c'est pas son vrai
vélo là c'est un éloquent en partie
rapide donc ça n'a absolument rien à
voir avec ça
mais je serai pas du tout
choqué ou étonné s'il avait à peu près
le même vélo en blitz je peux vous la
chercher si vous voulez vous le cherchez
on va voir
on va voir un peu ses vélos
je l'ai trouvé là je vais j'avais vu
juste il a 25 60 en feed alors que
j'avais dit qu'il avait environ entre
60-70 donc je suis assez bon en rapide
il a 24 95 ça c'est pas beaucoup et en
blitz il a 25 60 donc je pense pas qu'il
est beaucoup joué depuis après c'est un
joueur qui avait sûrement qu'il a fait
en blé de thérapie et il avait peut-être
beaucoup moins d'élo que ça vous savez
qu'il y avait plein de joueurs qui sont
jeunes qui jouent quasiment pas dans ces
cadrans de jeux là dans leur pays des
fois ils ont pas ils ont pas tout
simplement le tournoi
donc voilà et c'est un joueur qui a qui
a
17 ans
donc c'est vraiment un joueur qui est
tout jeune encore et mais il sera
bientôt 2006 et peut-être même plus
encore c'est un joueur qui est
extrêmement talentueux et déjà on le
voit en blitz le but c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un jeu un peu de réflexe
et déjà quand tu es très très bon en
blitz généralement c'est parce que tu
peux pas rentrer vraiment
à fond dans le calcul donc toujours
avoir des coûts surtout que tu passes
par la tête et c'est plus on va dire sur
le calcul court que tu as vraiment une
compréhension du jeu en elle-même donc
c'est un peu différent mais le fait
d'être très bon en blitz déjà très jeune
surtout et ben ça montre à quel point il
est là il est talentueux parce qu'il est
capable de repérer très très vite
il a un bon feeling quoi
donc voilà donc j'ai trois là Carona qui
va absolument faire son petit F4 pour
attaquer et là vous avez qui sait pas
encore où mettre son roi donc la petite
robe c'est pas possible pour l'instant à
cause du Fou en H6 et grand rock et ben
je pense que Carona il attend de pied
ferme le grand rock pour jouer B4
il y a des cas qui risque d'être envoyé
quasiment tempo en tout cas moi je suis
en vérité
parce que V4 ça permet d'ouvrir un peu
les colonnes et ça a l'air pas mal
ensuite B4 peut-être que c'est pas si
clair
ça reste solide et que le pion BK
c'est une possibilité
voilà faire B7
tout ça mais bon
par principe là tu es mené dans le match
à être mis 0 et demi enfin
de 1 il y a eu deux nuls et une victoire
pour la varie et bien tu as envie de
prendre des risques et laisser pousser
des quatre donc la page de valeur il a
fait la fête à mes deux et je pense que
moi j'aurais fait des tempo bon après
c'est mon style j'aime bien les
positions il faut attaquer et je pense
que j'aurais fait le 4 ce sont pas un
bon goût mais c'est pour ça que je suis
pas leur niveau mais B4 c'est un coup
qui me démangeait et je pense qu'il
serait parti tout seul
voilà voilà donc dame 2 mais après bien
sûr le V4 qui va partir un jour c'est
sûr dans ce cas préparer avec ces trois
points de B4 où est-ce qu'il va partir
B4 direct maintenant qu'il a perdu un
temps dame 2 et que le Fou est plus
défendu ici en
6 maintenant de sens à mon à mon à mon
groupe parce que maintenant je sais pas
ce qu'il peut manger là en tout cas ça
c'est plus une menace
B4 A4 pour fermer la position bah jamais
pas
ton proposition Joker parce qu'en fait
maintenant mon pion il est bien donc là
maintenant j'ai du C4 avec ce pion en
prise et là tu vois une possibilité de
pouvoir jouer 5 plus tard et j'ai
l'impression que les Blancs maintenant
sont sont pas mal elles peuvent
continuer à attaquer faire ce pion des
cartes qui était faible une fois qu'on
le joueur je pense l'option un jour il
est imprenable donc je passe ça au sein
dans tous les cas ce pion était quand
même mal barré mais si tu laisses la
colonne fermée j'avais l'impression que
les blancs sont tirés plutôt pas mal
donc
je n'ai pas le coup à 4 pour les noirs
mais bon après peut-être que c'était bon
mais moi je n'ai pas trop et là il y a
eu fou à 3 donc il va vraiment préparer
je pense la pousser tranquillement soit
C4 B4 soit c'est 3 et 4 mais il va
essayer de pousser
de pousser la plaque on est quand même
posé moi j'ai petit rock entre donc
c'est clair que elle va partir là-bas
pour pour les blancs et je passe mettre
internet
c'est bien ça
et ça fait un moment que je l'attendais
et c'est finalement ça finit par payer
et
voilà donc j'attends congrès de la fibre
pour que ça va valider par la Fédération
internationale des échecs donc ça prend
quelques mois donc je les fais en août
donc je sais pas je dirais
je dirais entre entre décembre
si j'ai pas de chance
ou avant tu as de la chance mais bon peu
importe en vrai je m'en fous un peu
l'important c'est que je l'ai maintenant
le lieu d'administratif
c'est maintenant B4 va être va être
balancé
donc impeccable on prend ici les Blancs
ont une grosse attaque sur la colonne A
sur la colonne B d'ailleurs assez facile
donc comme C5 a l'air assez logique pour
essayer de ne pas permettre aussi
facilement là par exemple je pourrais
manger un truc comme ça donc j'ai un
pion de plus avec les Noirs certes que
l'on est ouvertes mais le pion est
toujours là donc à voir à voir si c'est
vraiment vraiment grave mais en tout cas
la B4 va être le coup le coup ici
joué par Fabi comment je rejette depuis
très longtemps que j'aurais perdu
d'ailleurs ce pion mais j'aurais gagné
la colonne chacun son style mais ouais
ça marche je crois ça
je ne sais pas
sûrement moyen de chercher tu vas sortir
de la feed et tu regardes sur les les
joueurs internationaux les titrés il y a
sûrement un moyen de trouver comment il
y a de vous mettre dans le monde en tout
cas dans le monde je suis à peu près
1500e il me semble si on regarde si vous
êtes sur mon profil feed d'ailleurs si
vous marquez mon nom et mon prénom sur
sur le site de la feed et ben vous
trouvez le classement dans le monde et
je dois être environ 1500e dans le monde
bon ce qui est plutôt pas mal
tu as il y a 1300 km actifs c'est à 1300
actifs 1300 km actifs
je suis pas mal quand même
mais 1500 sur combien sur combien de
millions de gens d'échec c'est pas si
mal en vrai
mais bon on essaiera de faire mieux on
essaiera de faire un peu mieux
mais je sais pas les trucs après
peut-être que si vous avez les infos sur
la feed
ben tu peux peut-être partir je sais pas
j'ai reçu obtenir 2400 ouais et c'est
pour cette raison là que je passe sinon
bah oui c'est clair c'est clair
mais en fait c'est clair
parce que là tu peux dire
je suis loin mais quand tu regardes
combien il y a le joueur d'échec dans le
monde bah en fait c'est pas mal
parce qu'en France je suis en top 100 je
crois
pas non plus incroyable mais j'attends
80-90 comme ça
si ça
après je vais faire un tour derrière
parce que j'étais passé à 2411
d'ailleurs
et
je suis revenu après je suis revenu
après je suis revenu après
et j'ai fait j'ai fait deux tournois
très bon
dont un qui fait pas 2400 et après ça le
relâchement j'ai fait un autre tournoi
et j'ai fait la catastrophe mais bon là
on est vraiment sur le fait qu'on est
relâché c'était un peu moins important
et du coup voilà mais il faut essayer de
digérer ce titre et repartir de belles
prises
et attention parce que même là je te
reprends à 6 qui est une idée
intéressante des fois on va prendre et
chèque suivi de dessin qui est vraiment
c'est tout cassé il y a des il y a quand
même des
des possibilités côté blanc même cavalet
B3 venir sur sa case là même C4 B5
franchement c'est chaud c'est chaud le
blanc il est aussi assez ouvert vous
voyez il y a des idées aussi mais j'ai
quand même l'impression que le roi blanc
qui aime plus protégé
intéressant peut-être que c'est par
cavalier F3 pour empêcher F3 qui mène à
quand même assez fort F3 la marche 3 ça
a l'air pas mal
merci à toi Ikana kaway j'ai pas encore
fait la vidéo d'ailleurs la vidéo où je
passe mettre internationale je l'ai pas
encore fait je comptais la faire très
très bientôt et à publier sur sur
YouTube dans d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
sont pas à bossés abonnés à YouTube
alors déjà on va commencer à faire la
pub pour pièces comme fr alors vous êtes
pour ceux qui peuvent nous voir sur
twitch ou aussi sur ce comme FR en
direct aujourd'hui n'hésitez pas à
lâcher votre follow aux différentes
chaînes c'est gratuit et vous restez
informé de tout ce qui se passe sur les
chaînes donc c'est vraiment très très
bien nous ça nous aide et vous en plus
ça vous aide aussi donc c'est assez cool
et en parallèle moi je stream aussi sur
ma chaîne et j'ai aussi une chaîne
Youtube de mon côté donc pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas et ben je suis stouf
vous voyez en dessous de mon nom et
prénom il y a marqué stuff ça c'est mon
pseudo twitch et pour YouTube et ben
c'est tout échec
et je suis à côté
et j'ai pas mal de vidéos qui sont
faites des shorts des vraies vidéos des
road to Amy
des speedruns pas mal de petites choses
donc allez fouiller un peu voir ce qui
vous va il y a plein d'ouvertures aussi
qui sont faites et voilà voilà donc
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à vous abonner
aux différentes chaînes que ce soit sur
cheese.fr sur sur mes chaînes à moi
perso et très très bientôt je vous
mettrai d'ailleurs la vidéo de mon
passage à mettre international donc la
partie qui m'a fait passer 2400 hello
virtuellement c'est pour un genre que
vous connaissez bien si vous avez
l'habitude de passer sur ma chaîne et
ben j'ai joué contre Pierre tu dégages
donc pas touche 0,6 c'est un maître
international qui est qui est souvent
sur ma chaîne en tant qu'invité etc et
je contre lui pour le titre et j'ai
gagné la partie donc je ferai la vidéo
je la prends en fait et de la publierai
et puis là vous pourrez voir un peu tout
ça ça va être vraiment hyper cool merci
beaucoup de charpentier pour ton petit
message ça fait plaisir
mais voilà c'était vraiment beaucoup de
travail en tout cas et d'acharnement
pour ce titre donc il y a des gens qui
arrivent plus facilement que d'autres
mais il y en a pour qui ben c'est plus
dur que de aussi donc voilà en tout cas
il faut toujours continuer et croire en
soi et malgré le fait que c'est
difficile
et ben il faut toujours continuer
j'aime non j'ai l'épée sur terre
ikanaka
je
n'ai pas je pense que je n'ai pas le
talent et je ne fournirai pas le travail
pour faire ses grands maîtres
c'est beaucoup d'investissement beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de temps
tout ça finalement pour pas grand chose
parce que
là si je venais si je vais venir
remettre demain je pense pas que ça va
changer ma vie tu vois là je travaille
dans les échecs je suis en train de lire
des chèques alors je donne des cours
pour ceux qui voudraient progresser
aussi c'est mon métier je suis en train
de chèque
et
là être grand maître de main au final
ça a pas changé
beaucoup mes choses
quand même
le fou qui a l'air un petit peu enfermé
et après je garde il se passe quoi parce
que si je prends là je suis pas
totalement
à voir ce qui se passe mais ça a l'air
intéressant en tout cas car voilà qui a
pas mal de temps à la vente aussi
donc pour finir rapidement avec ta
question et Kanaka non je suis trop trop
difficile trop d'investissement pour
finalement pas grand chose voilà il y a
pas grand chose au final c'est un type
de Grand Maître qui est très bien mais
pour moi
au final ça signifie pas grand chose
enfin être en maths c'est énorme mais je
veux dire
je suis très loin de en termes de niveau
de la voir
et du coup je pense pas que le travail
va vraiment tous les efforts que j'ai
fournir tous les efforts le temps etc
c'est pour ça que je ne mets pas pour
l'instant je sais que j'ai pas de niveau
que je le serai pas pour l'instant mais
si un jour je progresse et je monte à
2450 ou quasiment 2500 par hasard et ben
peut-être qu'à ce moment là waouh
peut-être qu'à ce moment là je pose la
question et si je suis pas très loin je
pourrais les fesses quoi mais pour
l'instant je suis tellement loin que
franchement je préfère être honnête avec
vous et vous dire que je pense que c'est
trop dur plutôt que de vous faire rêver
avec un rôle que j'aime qui n'arrivera
nulle part parce que je sais très très
bien que je ne serai pas grand maître
voilà alors c'est pas c'est quoi du coup
sur 5
G4 là je me lance je comprends rien
ça va les prendre le 4
coups priant surprise main
et prendre en fait
et si tu prends là je prends la jolie
[Musique]
et du coup si tu bouges ton fou
tu perds la pièce ouais c'est joli comme
si c'était possible avec l'idée de
manger ici on raciste
surprise là je prends là et du coup les
blesses de mode avec toi il y a
plusieurs possibilités mais bon dans
tous les cas c'est extrêmement dur mais
vous voyez que le roi noir il est
beaucoup plus en danger que le roi blanc
en fait au final roi blanc il est ici
toutes les pièces noires sont cachées
donc au final c'est bien plus facile à
jouer pour les blancs que pour les noirs
et la David qui est vraiment très très
grande difficulté fin cette partie qui
risque de perdre cette partie et en cas
de défaite de la vanille et ben ça fera
2 2 et on aura droit à un armage gueton
avec enchères ça vous savez déjà parlé
ces enchères ces fameuses enchères
comment ça marche tout ça
donc on va voir au revoir pour l'instant
je pense que je pense que Fabi est très
très bien parti pour gagner
cette partie
les plus possible pour les Noirs si je
prends là
je prends tout non
ça
ça marchera pas
là c'est pareil
ça je vais vous prendre
ça j'ai pu en prendre cette bouche
ça se voit que le roi il est extrêmement
faible après je sais pas peut-être qu'il
y a des choses mais par exemple B5 alors
très fort la chose elle est pas d'accord
avec moi mais moi j'aimais bien
parce que on prend j'avais une
un échec double qui va gagner la dame
et surprendre pareil avec ton propre B5
et si tu prends bah j'ai galéré
quand même pas mal mais l'ordinateur et
tout de défense tel que des 5 qui fait
que c'est pas clair mais l'ordinateur il
est trop dur il est trop fort donc du
coup des fois on
on pense un peu à tout ça donc là il
faut je crois apparemment il faut que je
travaille G5
qui a la recherche assez logique dans
l'idée que la 36 je crois que c'est
l'idée de la position et sur reprendre
ici donc ça c'est plus humain mais c'est
simple fallait le voir sachant que P5
avait la canne très fort dans tous les
cas c'est très très dur pour lasalik
qu'il a surprendre la tête et il y a
plus que deux minutes à la pendule ça a
l'air très difficile pour lui
et
Carla est tranquille il a l'air confiant
et qu'elle prend sa main dans la tête
mais elle a rien assez confiance même au
temps ça se voit le temps
c'est
un facteur qui est important
salut Greg merci à toi
et bienvenue ici vous avez des questions
dans notre chat n'hésitez pas n'hésitez
pas ça peut être des questions bien sûr
liées
lié à la partie liée à tout ça mais ça
peut être aussi
des questions qui sont liées à autre
chose on va quand même c'est dans le
monde des échecs même si vous avez des
questions par rapport à moi quoi que ce
soit n'hésitez pas là on est sur une
seule partie
c'est bien si on veut parler un petit
peu donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas le
chat
fous c'est ça
OK
les Scorpion
ça m'a l'air très très dur mais écoutez
il faut jouer un coup
fallait faire un coup alors si moi
naïvement je prends la et tu prends la
et je prends la qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est le coup qu'elle a quand même
ultra facile ultra normal il y a les
vis-à-vis de partout ça a l'air terrible
je vois pas du tout comment on se défend
sur ça
je cherche tactique sans regarder j'aime
bien des fois regarder en l'air c'est
des fois on réfléchit en regardant en
l'air
je pensais à un truc comme
ça
marcher j'aurais voulu faire un truc du
style là pour manger là pour manger
le problème c'est que
quand je fais ça pour laisser madame bah
tu manges c'est bien et quand je
branlette mange du cavalière donc
j'arrive pas à obtenir cette position de
jouer donc c'est pour ça que je suis pas
faim
mais il y a peut-être juste
[Musique]
les quatre en fait qui a l'air suffisant
je pense
mes quatre ça va quand même pas mal il y
a pas le seul du tout
je bouge mon cavalier et maintenant tu
restes avec ton fond en prise démarre
toi
F3 d'un bouche du coup là il faut
défendre le pion quand même
et après tu es fou ce fou et ben il est
perdu il va être perdu il est pas
défendable et il y a trop de problèmes
j'avoue que j'aurais pas trop aimé
[Musique]
j'aurais pas trop aimé avancer par
principe ça fait peur
j'ai absolument pas l'attaque mais bon
par principe
qui avait l'air plus forte en tout cas
hello Steph tu viens de dire que l'ordi
avait quelques fois des raisonnements
trop puissant penses-tu qu'on est
atteint un plafond aujourd'hui dans 5
ans sans capote
je pense qu'on l'a déjà enfin
là je pense que on n'a pas du tout
atteint les plafonds
et mais c'est clair qu'il y a des ordis
qui sont quand même bien meilleur que
d'autres on a le faire zéro alpha zéro
qui est d'ailleurs pas ouvert au public
et qui allait jouer un match contre tous
les stocks finis les
modules existants actuellement et
c'était une humiliation c'était une
humiliation je sais plus quel était le
score du match ils avaient jeté je sais
pas sans parti quoi c'était un truc de
fou le match
je crois qu'il avait perdu 0 partis il
avait gagné la moitié et que les nuls
c'est un truc de fou
et quand tu voyais des parties
maintenant c'est un truc de fou
alors dit que ça fait toutes ces pièces
tout le temps hyper
c'était vraiment tout pour l'initiative
tout le temps et même les ordinateurs de
maintenant de ces stock fiches de
maintenant
à ce que tu fais quand même mais les
ordis en fait ils s'en foutent quoi
enfin alpha zéro c'était juste ça a
l'impression que c'était
l'échec du
[Musique]
XIXe
qui faisait des gambies et que tout
passait pas tu as vraiment l'impression
que tous les Gambie marchaient alors
qu'actuellement les gambies ou ça que
faisait plus on marche plus trop mais
elle est mais
à face zéro tu fais voir qu'en fait
l'initiative est tellement importante
que même lui a son niveau alpha zéro et
ben tu as vu des pions et des pièces
tout le temps contre tous les programmes
et les bassins
et c'est vraiment un jeu qui est
complètement différent de tout ce qu'on
a pu voir dans les autres programmes
tu fais trop d'un projet 3
28 secondes pour laservic et la position
qui est qui est extrêmement difficile à
tenir il y a tout en prison il a fait ça
des fois en prise aussi il y a du P5
partout
pour réaliser à quel point la position
de sa vie est mieux l'ordi
d'une heure à 0,5
[Musique]
coups après tu te rends compte mais bon
c'est un truc de malade c'est un truc de
malade c'est l'impression qu'il joue au
hasard enfin tu as l'impression qu'il
fait n'importe quoi en fait parce que tu
es pas assez fort pour comprendre
et enfin tu vois même même stock fish il
est pas assez fort pour comprendre stop
il comprend pas
c'est plein de cours après tu as 30
cours après que stock fiche se rend
compte stockfish en fait c'est
intéressant
quand tu as Google qui s'y met quand
même en termes de puissance nordique etc
de modules ça devient dur mais du coup
actuellement les meilleurs modules à
part alpha zéro à plat mais ils sont
tous à peu près équivalents
mais alpha zéro il est venu il a
massacré tout le monde quoi donc en fait
et ça c'est pas encore une limite ils
ont juste fait comme ça mais je pense je
pense que
ça va depuis remplir en fait et je pense
que l'ordinateur il va finir par tuer
les échecs si c'est pas déjà plus ou
moins fait quoi parce que c'est vrai
quand même que
[Musique]
faire un peu attention aussi au niveau
des échecs parce que c'est vrai que nous
on aime bien un jour d'échec
et l'ordinateur
il est un peu trop fort quoi pour nous
c'est exactement ça Greg je ne doute pas
que du mieux est toujours possible je
m'intéresse on a fait pour avoir envie
de puissance qu'il faisait et ben écoute
c'est très possible
qu'il le soit parce que je pense pas que
Google quand ils ont fait leur programme
à zéro
je suis pas sûr qu'il se soit beaucoup
pris la tête aussi
voilà par contre ça sent le matin à
planer dans mes trois là on va avoir un
abandon très vite
attention en maths
là mais juste je mets une pièce devant
on est dans F3
ça a l'air juste complètement perdu ça
marche trop à très fort aussi fou des 7
donc là il y a plus de maths
possible et les Noirs quand même il faut
rien mais ils sont là ça a un petit peu
attention
donc là attention
aussi c'est le coup que j'aurais fait
tout recettes peut-être
alors franchement je peux pas je fais
malheureusement
c'est gagnant mais il faut encore
terminé il faut s'encara bien faut que
j'ai 3 j'aime bien faire ça comme ça on
part tous les matins possibles et après
on va se régler
simple
il y a un peu naturel dans le jeu
j'avance plus vite qu'on pense je crois
que l'échec est encore beaucoup à sa
meilleure partie
[Musique]
ouais si tu veux pourquoi pas après je
pense que tu connais mieux que moi du
coup
moi tout ça
il a enfin échangé ce fou qui était plus
que gênant et maintenant regardez il y a
trois pièces pour la tour avec le roi à
poil et qui arrive c'est complètement
complètement perdu ben écoutez très
belle partie en tout cas de de
carwana dans cette dans cette partie et
car voilà qui vient égaliser au score
donc on arrive à deux deux maintenant
dans ce match donc on va voir maintenant
un petit peu ce que nous font ces
joueurs je vous rappelle que comme les
joueurs sont de deux et ben ce qui va se
passer ici
c'est que
c'est qu'en fait
c'est qu'en fait les joueurs vont
choisir leur couleur un peu par enchères
donc là ce qui se passe c'est que chaque
joueur va donner un temps avec lequel il
est d'accord de jouer avec les noirs et
le joueur qui aura donné le temps le
plus petit et ben on aura les Noirs donc
gagnera l'enchère donc aura les noirs du
coup et donc il aura les noirs et le et
il pourra faire nul donc celui qui
allait noir peut faire nul et gagner
pour se qualifier par contre celui qui a
les blancs à l'obligation de gagner pour
se qualifier mais bon il y a des blancs
plus de temps donc l'avantage des blancs
l'avantage le plus de temps mais en cas
de nul il passe pas donc c'est assez
faire comme chose la cadence c'est du
chaos donc il y a pas de rajout de temps
entre les coups
du coup on va attendre un petit peu
alors moi je reste connecté à mon slack
avec
les nouvelles que généralement et ben
donnent ici les nouvelles
pour les armagidon qui vont arriver
donc là pour l'instant j'ai pas encore
de nouvelles on m'a juste dit que
l'Armageddon comment serait dans 10
minutes donc je vais faire une petite
pause 5 minutes et je reviens pour
débriefer un petit peu et pour le
lancement de cet Armagan donc qui pose
et je reviens tout de suite bougez pas à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis de retour pour cet
Armageddon et je n'ai pas trouvé
sur mon slack le
enchères
du coup je ne sais pas
je sais pas quels sont les anciens des
parties
je ne sais pas qui est le blanc et
qu'elle est noir
mais je dès que je sais je vous dis
mais pour l'instant j'ai rien donc les
accusations sont sur
Fabi j'ai absolument
rien entendu
et puis j'en sais rien
donc on verra peut-être si ça sort pour
l'instant je n'ai rien entendu sur lui
et en tout cas elle a une tête d'être
quelqu'un de très sympathique donc on
verra bien pour l'instant je ne suis au
courant de rien on en rencontre et
j'espère d'ailleurs qu'il y aura rien
parce que
en vrai c'est
triste des fois quand on
se rend compte de choses qui sont
passées etc des plaintes sur des gens
qu'on connaît des fois c'est vrai que
c'est
on croit connaître quelqu'un mais en
fait des fois bah c'est pas le cas mais
j'espère que tu n'auras pas de problème
en tout cas
avec Fabi et du coup j'ai toujours pas
la partie qui est lancée et sur mon
slack j'ai toujours ah si si j'ai la
zavik qu'il a donné 9 minutes 30
et Fabi a donné 9 58 donc là zavik a
gagné l'enchère donc aura les noirs
donc voilà il y aura les Noirs donc
fabira les blancs
et dernière partie Fabi 15 minutes
contre 9,30 Sabi est obligé de gagner la
partie en cas de nul c'est David qui
passera
dans la poule des gagnants en
demi-finale et qui laissera à l'abandon
notre ami
ça vient
voilà voilà pour pour les petits gossip
pour les news de
de cette dernière enfin je te donne une
quart de finale qui oppose ici car wanna
contre laservic on a deux deux pour
l'instant
c'est pas de nuls puis une victoire de
lasalik et Carla rapidement je peux vous
montrer aussi
le petit
braquet qui est ici avec Carsen qui a
gagné 2 et demi à 0 et demi Tabata
en train de jouer le gagnant de Spar
Magellan jouera contre Karl scène
ensuite on aura so qui a mis 3-0 à
elianov sauf qui se qualifie en
demi-finale et qui va affronter fil
rouge Jack lionne ou a aussi mis 3-0
mais a besoin de Rohff et franchement
Abdou full battre et 3-0 c'est un
exploit c'est énorme Abdul avec un gagné
une une édition précédente qui a
quelques mois et donc tabac tabaye il va
attendre dans le bracket des loosers il
va attendre le perdant entre la Dali et
Carolin pendant que Eliano
et Abdou vont se jouer dans le
premier bracket du coup des perdants ici
donc voilà ça c'est le c'est le le
bracket pour l'instant et il manque
encore une place en demi-finale ici
contre 45 qui va se jouer en armée donc
ici quelques instants
voir si la partie est lancée je l'ai ici
et la partie a commencé on est peut-être
dans le début et ici du coup
c'est le début tout à l'heure c'est le
même début à peu près vous voyez c'est
l'espagnol
c'est l'espagnol
avec le Francis très vite et qu'elle
aille les deux ce changement structure
assez intéressant où les Blancs jouent
pour la structure de pion et il y a eu
ici d'un point de 6 donc ça doit assez
vite je vous rappelle que c'est du chaos
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a pas de
rajout de temps
entre chaque coup et donc là il y a 9
minutes 14 ko contre 14,23 il y a pas
trois zones parcours on aurait pu voir
avant
ok donc ok donc cavaler F5 que j'ai 6
qui a validé 3
et donc un peu comment ça va se jouer
alors souvent les Blancs jouent pour F4
c'est un plan assez thématique
dans ces positions
et les Noirs jouent plus avec un blanc
pour une cavalier en 6 des fois comme
par exemple le tour des 8 cavaliers
fuite cavaliers aussi ce genre de choses
pour s'enlever moi je pensais vite ici
peut-être et faire dame G7 essayer de
défendre le pion en
G7 c'est ce qui va c'est évidemment
le roi qui va sûrement revenir en G8 ou
en G7
donc je trouve ça sympa de faire H4 H5
dès que le roi est parti là-bas du coup
on gagne un temps plus tard pour qu'on
le roi repartira ici
donc voilà moi ça m'a l'air OK un truc
comme ça
qui peut arriver avec même carré les
trois aussi intéressant je trouve que la
potion de blanche à l'intérieur récente
elle est prise prise prise ok donc
mais il pense qu'il y a pas forcément
d'attaque intéressant
alors moi j'ai 7 c'est la partie ça a
été joué
et après moi j'ai 7
comment est-ce qu'on joue avec les
Blancs
revenir ici j'ai F4 qu'elle a aussi pas
mal
j'aime bien j'aime bien tout ça
un jour
en tout cas oui c'est fou qui est
monstrueux en B2 très bien placé ce fou
F4 qui va arriver un jour il va tout
ouvrir sur la diagonale les blancs sont
extrêmement bien
et en plus de ça il y a beaucoup de
temps d'avance à la pendule il y a des
problèmes à résoudre rapidement
chez les Noirs peut-être B6
et bien si j'ai envie de faire F4
aussi
je peux venir ici
je vais aussi F4 qui peut arriver très
vite sur sa case là
on va attaquer là il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes en fait dans la
position
intéressante de 4 ans j'aime beaucoup la
position des blancs en tout cas la
famille
[Musique]
Fabi qui va peut-être faire la surprise
enfin la surprise la remontada on va
dire parce que c'est qu'un pas une
surprise c'est se qualifie dans ce match
mais il est perdu une partie et là il
faut gagner deux parties pour se
qualifier et de gagner une avec ma
manière d'ailleurs et la deuxième et
déjà bien partie aussi pour lui donc là
je pense que Fabi est parti pour pour
gagner une deuxième partie d'affilée
tout re 8 blance bien la case de 5
maintenant est-ce que je peux manger ici
si je mange pas en prendre quoi prendre
du foot peut-être pour changer les fous
voilà pas mal
si je mange du Fou
faire attention au pion c'est ça un jour
cavalier prendre aussi pas mal attaque
la dame
mais je pense que les Noirs vont réussir
à obtenir un petit blocus sur la carte
de 5 là ici il y a eu ces quatre
je prends le centre
et là c'est dur pour le droit de faire
un cours en fait
c'est que là pour les Noirs il faut
trouver un coup une idée
pas évident
déjà t'es pas le meilleur coup de mon
ordi maintenant alors moi je préférais
F4 parce qu'en fait par instant je m'en
fous
donc j'avais bien F4
ou alors
dans cette cadence là c'est du chaos
c'est l'Armageddon
et donc dans l'Armageddon c'est très
difficile à jouer pour pour le noir
parce qu'ils ont pas de plan rien à
faire des sacs avec les jouets on prend
vraiment de l'espace
et je pense qu'il se garde F5 plus tard
donc là qu'est-ce qu'on va faire non on
peut je sais 5 pour fermer la position
mais on peut aussi
voilà manger pour garder les cases pour
nos pièces donc Fulla malheureusement je
te reprends C7 et qu'à valider 5 par
exemple alors intéressant aussi
j'ai toujours P4 faut voir mais est-ce
que les Noirs arrivent à s'activer un
petit peu ou pas c'est la grande
question est-ce que qui avait 5 est
possible c'est la partie on va un peu ce
qui se passe des cartes qui avaler des
trois et cavaliers F4 c'est un coup que
j'aurais probablement joué tempo avec
les Noirs parce que tu as besoin de
bouger tu as besoin de t'activer tu as
besoin de faire des choses comme ça
je pense c'est avant le coup humain que
nous fait ici à laser
il était ici il est venu là pour
empêcher ça qui perd un temps et l'autre
il fait ça ça avec les Noirs donc c'est
pas quoi faire
B4 je reviens et les rois qui part en F8
et le fou qui revient en C1 qui va
revenir en E3 peut-être
regarder F4 et en fait au fur et à
mesure et ben il garde toutes les
possibilités
regardez le roi qui est mal placé en 7
ans il faut être en forme c'est pas un
bon coup il y avait mieux que ça mais
c'est un coup qui est très logique faut
prendre c'est pas possible à cause de
cette
et
je garde encore toutes les possibilités
d'attaque F4 pour une possibilité encore
ramener la dame aussi peut être pas mal
comme faire attention à dommage 7 un peu
caché pour un jour faire peur un peu au
blanc mais c'est que le cavalier quand
même pour bien un quart d'heure je pense
pas qu'il y aura de matte en tout cas
pas tout de suite
dès que tu bouges c'est aussi de la
préciser chaque donc c'est dur pour le
noir quand même vous voyez que j'ai du
mal à bouger j'ai pas de possibilité
et il faut quand même trouver un plan
comment est-ce que je peux améliorer
dans le cavalier donc lui il est bien
placé la dame aussi et la dame contre
l'acadesie
donc maintenant il faut trouver un truc
à faire pour le Cavaillon peut-être
qu'elle a cavailler
on va manger le flou des 6 et essayer de
voir un peu la position donc 9 minutes
pour les blancs contre 5
donc c'est du chaos encore une fois
c'est du chaos et là je pense qu'avec ce
coup tour H5 les Noirs veulent peut-être
faire F5
et encore fou j'ai 5 mais 5 c'est une
idée des noirs
[Musique]
ici F5 pas encore possible j'ai trop
d'échec de partout
je passe sur un coup comme ça pour jouer
parce que c'est quand même qui fait un
peu peur quand même
pas trop de faire avec les Noirs quand
même il revient là quand même
donc là du coup ça fait deux fois même
position attention pas répéter là si on
répète Kawana qui permet la partie
instantanément parce que la nul ferait
gagner laser
pour B5 on rend la case du cavalier en
C5 mais attention qui est cinq perdez à
cause de faux français 5
puis on prend et ben j'ai B6 et avec le
clouage ça va tout ouvrir et ça va
gagner donc même si la case
5 on y va pas maintenant ton G8 la
partie
et maintenant comment on continue
peut-être ta marche 3 là pas mal qui
empêche la tour de venir sur la colonne
h et garde aussi la classe E6 de la dame
F7 mercure ça si tu bouges là quoi tu
peux plus bouger la dame et la tour non
plus donc là tu as un petit peu vissé tu
as plus grand chose à jouer avec les
noirs lui bouge pas à cause de ça et à
cause de problèmes sur cavaliers bon
j'ai l'impression qu'après ça marche 3
c'est quasiment un jeu en fait les noirs
peuvent plus bouger une seule pièce et
un jeu fou c'est un ok il attend il sait
pas quoi faire
peut-être d'un meuf 3 et X3 c'est une
idée peut-être
pour essayer de changer comme ça
peut-être c'est le milieu de
famille on va voir
tomber 8 en tout cas les deux Georges
jouent vite
il y a des problèmes clairs pour pour
les Noirs mais bon tu es mal au temple
il faut il faut trouver une solution ça
marche 3 avec les jeux maintenant
qui est très mal n'a pas de plan il y a
pas de plans
mais il faut jouer des coups
ça va être peut-être son
idée hein
sur YouTube
salut à toi bonne soirée à toi on est
dans la partie de la magazine de ce
match
avec qui vit en C4 ça a l'air trop dur 7
minutes pour les blancs contre 4 pour le
noir
et la position qui a l'air franchement
un jouable mais complètement jouable
pour les Noirs c'est un moment déjà que
je sais pas quoi faire
et après il y a ça en l'air il y a plein
de choses en l'air c'est un petit peu
trop dur
et le bras il doit s'engager
ou pas à cause de ça
[Musique]
lui il joue pas parce qu'il y a un
clouage quand il faut garder le pion B6
et lui je vois ce qu'il faut défendre la
en fait c'est un peu genre
que les blancs sont hyperactifs ils font
tout ce qu'ils veulent
vous savez 5 peut-être mais bon enfin
j'ai toujours trouvé ça
va être perdant comment en fait
ça laisse la marche 3 et ça mais même
même sans tour G8
franchement la pollution est beaucoup
trop dure
ici tu manges du pion je prends là déjà
c'est perdu
donc là il faut manger du roi quoi
alors qu'est-ce que nous faire notre ami
Fabi
voit des choses tu as l'impression que
il est pas content je crois il est pas
content
[Musique]
vu la jauge
waouh ça fait une pièce Fabi sur
cavalier
du matériel elle a place sur un pion
prend fou prend attaque la tour et si il
bouge la tour je prends en dessert donc
ça a l'air complètement terminé cette
partie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut bien faire tour ici
il faut prendre les chèques
et sur on apprend
pour là autour là je dirais pour que
j'ai facile
dame et cher c'est pas du tout la chose
elle est pas contente du tout
d'un point de vue humain ça n'a rien pas
mal tu vas échanger là faire ça et
pousser des pions mais c'est vrai
qu'apparemment il a pas été pressé du
tout
notre ami Fabi 5 42 contre 2 51
c'est du chaos je vous rappelle il y a
pas de rajout de temps
et il fait encore terminé la partie d'en
prendre
E8 échec reprend à 8
comment est-ce que je termine
tout là ça se défend je vais partir roi
ici tu as tort C6
pour faire un blocus peut-être
ça a pas l'air clair pour moi de comment
continuer cette partie
pas si
je continue
le roi aussi qui a l'air quand même pas
malin matériellement j'ai quand même une
tour et deux pions pour deux pièces donc
5 de pions ça fait 7 points contre 6
et en plus des plans passer un peu de
partout donc c'est clair que les blancs
sont beaucoup mieux mais il faut encore
la gagner en pratique c'est pas encore
c'est pas encore évident
ouais mais tu vois ce type de pions
comme tu me proposes là zakiron je suis
pas fan parce que là j'ai un peu passer
protéger que je peux pousser quand je
veux et le fait de pousser un peu trop
vite ça fait un peu peur parce qu'un
jour si jamais son roi a réussi à
s'activer ce pion sera perdu
alors que du coup j'ai pas envie de trop
rush à la à le pousser et des six qui
fait juste et au final
comme là tu vois et les fous cavaliers
contrôle la poussée B6 et après si le
pion était en D6 par exemple ben tu
pourrais
bouger le cavalier mettre leur en D7 et
ce pur en D6 en fait il viendrait faible
donc quand vous avez un pion passé
protéger comme ça et essayer de quand
même le garder un peu à la maison et
vous pousser au bon moment on passe trop
ce dépêcher à faire ça on a vraiment
tout notre temps ici
donc attention à 3,40 3,40 pour pour les
blancs donc ramenez le roi oui donc F3
d'abord pour défendre ce pion et après
ramener le roi donc où ça je ne sais pas
c'est pas facile je trouve vraiment un
passage pour le roi
soit tu fais F4 tu vas essayer de
trouver un passage avec le roi en
faisant un truc comme ça
soit tu passes par là mais bon c'est pas
évident de passer par là-bas parce que
je passe
pas facile de passer avec mon
donc à voir avoir
et il faut gagner
il faut gagner
ça
F3 G4 ou
un composteur c'est c'est ici pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas la géographie
espagnole
d'ailleurs le petit voyage de France a
composé c'est comme ça
on va d'ailleurs je crois qu'il est
comme il est même comme ça je crois
d'ailleurs
c'est parmi
il passe par là sur la carte espagnole
et là il faut savoir comment on fait
passer
je peux pas faire ça il y a toujours
deux fois deux pièces après des fois je
peux pousser
pour passer le roi mais bon c'est un
pion après il va te manger les miens
[Musique]
c'est pas évident du tout
il était gagnant et puis il a pas été
précis a priori c'est pas dur
alors n'importe quoi
c'est perdant c'est perdant chez
Carolina
les avis qui complètement gagnant qui va
les prendre ici
cavaler propion au début j'ai pensé
qu'il y avait ça à ça et je comprends
l'âme il y a échec après la prise échec
croix là tu fais dames je prends ici et
je récupère la dame et je suis
complètement gagnant que noir il y a pas
eu manger il y a eu cavalier
d'essai prise en F6 et on va les prendre
F6 et des blancs conservent leurs
chances de gain
et prenez pas le plus au moins il a le
prix il avait le truc en l'air non
l'idée c'est que tu prends pioche
exprès pour pas
et il a réussi à faire sa dame donc là
il y a une minute 10 contre une minute
c'est une position très tritive
vous voyez matériellement il a quand
même la cam a 3 + 3,6 +
1,709 donc les Noirs ont quand même
beaucoup de matériel contre contre la
dame et attention une dame ça fait un
café ça fait des fourchettes me faire
attention à ça et généralement par
rapport par rapport aux cavaliers il
faut essayer de se mettre loin avec la
dame alors si je prends là il y a une
fourchette attention
et c'est 5
allez le pion est perdu non toujours pas
et toi une fourchette
il a David c'est un joueur d'Internet
donc c'est un joueur qui peut clairement
flaguer la famille
enfin la cadence c'est du chaos 45 45
secondes
pour Fabi c'est du chaos
ça va jouer autant cette partie
c'est la zone
ou pas en fait
c'est vrai que ça a l'air quand même pas
mal pour les pour les pour les blancs
attention faut terminer
[Musique]
il faut terminer
j'arrive pas à passer
et pourtant il faut que je vide 27
secondes contre 43
gagne c'est nul
et ben c'est perdu même si même si
Caravana
a une dame contre cavalier si Caroline
contre rien
et Ben et ben gagne
enfin bon là
perdant alors qu'il a une dame contre
contre le roi et ben c'est nul et si
c'est nul
c'est nul et ben c'est nul donc le noir
gagne attention il y a plus de temps à
la pendule là
plus de temps du tout
le carré qui va être perdu ça va être
perdu ça va être amandon très très vite
et ouais
et tomber tomber donc ouais il aurait pu
à la fin essayer de mater je pense
qu'ici
sur échec il avait peut-être plus fort
quand même parce que
ici vous êtes cavalier
bouge donc il y a moyen de mater plus
vite à la fin et bon il a plus de temps
la pendule ils sont fous il veut juste
gagner autant je vois pas que c'est un
Flac c'est un flag c'est la vie bah j'ai
gagné dans la partie la cam dame
d'avance ce qui est incroyable ce qui
s'est passé ici regardez bien
la position était Archie gagnante au
début pour carvana qui a fait une très
très grosse partie d'un coup il a pas
été précis et la partie allait se
conclure en nul et ici là je
le coup ici E5 pour essayer de
obstruer le fou pour faire une dame ici
et ce qui va se passer c'est que sur
cavalier prend tour et ben je prends ça
fait échec et sur quoi prend si ce
madame et ben je fais tout prendre ici
échec entre le Dam et le roi et les
Noirs gagnent la partie ça a été raté
par les deux joueurs parce que
Carolina ici avec les Blancs pour
laisser la tour exprès parce qu'il a
pensé mais il a pas vu qu'il y avait
chacun récupérait la pièce et les Noirs
ont fait cavaler des 7
pour récupérer l'option
ça empêche la dame presque à valait
franc et sur le 53 ans il y a eu cette
finale qui est perdante pour le moment
extrêmement dur en tout cas à jouer pour
les deux joueurs en tout cas en tout cas
belle partie
des deux joueurs et voilà qui avance du
coup dans le tableau des vainqueurs on
regarde un petit peu le bracket on voit
demain c'est Caracal scène en
demi-finale déjà avec saut et cirrhose
là en demi-finale aussi des gagnants
alors que c'est les perdants on a
tabattabec contre la zavik et également
voilà voilà ça c'est pour le tableau et
demain on se revoit à partir de la même
heure on se revoit demain à partir de
de
17h pour encore plus de de
parties et encore plus de compétition
donc je vais partir acheter un petit
réel à se faire les gars avant de partir
est-ce qu'on se fait un petit raid avant
de partir ouais je pense qu'on fait un
petit raid chez lui alors les gars je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée on va
partir
chez un nouveau
partenaire c'est comme du stream donc je
vous dis à très bientôt le raid qui part
dans quelques instants merci beaucoup à
tous pour votre soutien et pour tout ce
que vous avez fait aujourd'hui en
suivant le stream je vous dis à demain à
17h passez une excellente soirée et à
très bientôt ciao ciao